[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this devops
tools full course by simply learn
in this complete course we learn
everything that we need regarding
several devops tools
we have matthews and chidanand to guide
us through this journey so let's look at
what's in store for us
we shall begin with having a basic
understanding of devops with a short
animated video
after that we'll dive deeper and
understand the basics of devops like its
relevance in the current scenario and
several devops phases
once we know devops we shall begin with
learning different devops tools in
detail
we shall learn about git followed by
github
and in the process
we shall learn about various git
commands
second we shall see what jenkins is
jenkins pipeline and how we install
jenkins
after that
we'll move on to docker and check out
what docker is and docker container is
all about
we'll also learn about the different
processes and how to install docker
moving further we'll understand the
basics of kubernetes the difference
between kubernetes and docker and
kubernetes on aws
the following tool in the list will be
puppet where we shall know what puppet
is and why we use puppet and the process
to install it
moving forward we learn about ansible
and its installation process and what
are the benefits of using ansible
the last tool on our list is selenium
where we shall learn about selenium and
all about its sweet tools followed by
its installation processes
while we're learning all these tools we
shall understand them with the hands-on
demo making the understanding much more
effective and more accessible
finally when we have a piece of
deep knowledge regarding devops and
several devops tools we'll look at some
of the most prominent devops interview
questions that will help you excel in
your forthcoming devops interviews
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure you hit the subscribe button and
the bell icon to never miss an update
so without further ado let's begin
right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team this
undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle
there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken and
this is called the devops approach the
devops symbol resembles an infinity sign
suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process
successful
the devops culture is implemented in
several phases with the help of several
tools let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like get and merged when
required this process is called version
control the code is then made executable
with tools like maven and gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code has passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase and
this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase
jenkins is the tool that sends the code
for building and testing if the code
passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration
there are many tech giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach for example amazon
netflix walmart facebook and adobe
netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007.
in 2014 it was estimated that a downtime
for about an hour would cost netflix two
hundred thousand dollars
however now netflix can cope with such
issues
they opted for devops in the most
fantastic way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment without
affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d
none of the above today more and more
companies lean towards automation with
the aim of reducing its delivery time
and the gap between its development and
operations teams to attain all of these
there's just one gateway
devops and if you're also looking
forward to doing the same and excel in
devops check out simply learn's
postgraduate program in devops design
and collaboration with caltech ctme the
program can help you master several
in-demand devops skills and tools
like continuous integration and delivery
devops on cloud kubernetes docker and
much more hello this is matthew with
simplylearn and today we're going to go
through and introduce you to devops
we're going to go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at devops and how devops
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical
devops delivery and then the tools used
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within devops finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
devops brings to you and your teams so
let's go through waterfall so waterfall
is a traditional delivery model that's
been used for many decades for
delivering solutions not just it
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history that
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming and you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using the watford model companies
have soon come to realize that you know
the clients just aren't able to get
their feedback in quickly effectively
it's very expensive to make changes once
the teams have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback
this allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works so this is
where devops really comes in and let's
dig into how devops which is developers
and operators working together is the
key for successful continuous delivery
so devops is as an evolution of the
agile model the agile model really is
great for gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the ops team and the
dev team and so with devops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on data so let's
step through the different phases of a
devops team so typically you'll see that
the devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
agile and what i'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
agile is that the coders actually start
coding but they typically they'll start
using tools such as git which is a
distributed version control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than bits of the code that is rather
than them working on bits of the code
that they are responsible for so the
goal with using tools such as git is
that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as maven and
gradle as a way to consistently build
out your environment and then we also
use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
devops tool set this really helps when
it comes to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing the
more effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this devops process so we go
through and we have a continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make a release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the build environment and
you want to be able to test the code
that you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the scripting test it can
then be deployed and once it's out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment what this provides you
is the opportunity to speed up your
delivery so you go from the waterfall
model which is weeks months or even
years between releases to agile which is
two weeks or four weeks depending on
your sprint cadence to where you are
today with devops where you can actually
be doing multiple releases every single
day so there are some significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are really zeroing in on
those advantages if we take any one of
these companies such as google google
any given day will actually process 50
to 100 new releases on their website
through their devops teams in fact they
have some great videos on youtube that
you can find out on how their devops
teams work netflix is also a similar
environment now what's interesting with
netflix is that netflix have really
fully embraced devops within their
development team and so they have a
devops team and netflix is a completely
digital company so they have software on
phones on smart tvs on computers and on
websites interestingly though the devops
team for netflix is only 70 people and
when you consider that a third of all
internet traffic on any given day is
from netflix it's really a reflection on
how effective devops can be when you can
actually manage that entire business
with just 70 people so there are some
key advantages that devops has it's the
actual time to create and deliver
software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to waterfall
complexity and maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating and
scripting out your entire environment
and you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos but
that are actually working cohesively
together and that there is continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
that your consumer your customer is
constantly being delighted a very warm
welcome to all our viewers i'm anjali
from simply learn and today i'll be
showing you the installation for git on
windows so we'll start by downloading
and installing git on our system we'll
then have a look at the git bash
interface we'll type in some basic git
commands next we'll create a local
repository that is we'll create a
repository on a local machine we'll then
connect to a remote repository and
finally we'll push the file onto github
first things first we need to download
and install git so download git for
windows and i'll select the second link
so
2.19.1 which is the most latest version
of kit that's the one we want for
windows system choose your version so
mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while
so git is
on our system
click here
run so go to next we don't have to
change this path
uh just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just tick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version 2.19.1
on our windows system which is exactly
what we just downloaded we'll now
explore the help command so let's just
type git help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it
so in case you have any doubts regarding
how a command is used what a command is
used for or the various syntax of the
command you can always use the help
command now there's another syntax for
using the help command itself which is
git config dash dash help enter this
does the exact same thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git init is the command for
initializing the directory and as you
can see as you can see the path here
this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test and
it's completely empty what we do now is
we'll create a text file within this new
directory that we created so new text
document and i'll just name this demo
i'll open this and just put in some
dummy content so hello simply done save
this file and go back to your bash
interface
let's just check the status now so git
status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is we
will be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the comment command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus m and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion
just clear the screen next thing we need
to do is we need to link our git to our
github account so the command for doing
that is git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is simplylearn.github
so guys before you begin this procedure
just make a github account type in my
username here simply learn github and
enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with github next
thing we do is we'll just open our
github
and we'll create a new repository give a
repository name so i'll name it test
underscore demo and create repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo thanks anjali now matthew and
chadanan will take you through the
remaining part of the course hello this
is matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to go through and explain
how you can use get for your software
development so what are we going to
cover today so we're going to introduce
the concept of version control that
you'll use within your devops
environment then we'll talk about the
different tools are available in a
distributed version control system we'll
highlight a product called git which is
typically used for version control today
and you'll also go through what are the
differences between get and github you
may have used github in the past or
other products like get lab and we'll
explain what are the differences between
git and git and services such as github
and git lab we'll break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like and how do you go through and
create forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally i'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as github all right let's talk a
little bit about version control systems
so you may have already been using a
virtual control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as microsoft's team
foundation services but essentially the
use of a virgin control system allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program that such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there will be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the version one changes that you had
then the person would then
later on check out that code and then be
a version two and add it to that code
and so you keep adding on versions of
that code the bottom line is that
eventually you'll have people being able
to use your code and that your code will
be stored in a centralized location
however the challenge you're running is
that it's very difficult for large
groups to work simultaneously within a
project the benefits of a vcs system a
version control system
demonstrates that you're able to store
multiple versions of a solution in a
single repository now let's take a step
at some of the challenges that you have
with traditional version control systems
and see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed vcs server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed vcs environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered git in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your git
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get git
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that
remote hub server git is used to track
the changes of the source code and
allows large teams to work
simultaneously with each other it
supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about git versus github so
get is a software tool whereas github is
a service and i'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tool for git locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service is actually hosted on a website
get is actually the software that used
to manage different versions of source
code whereas github is used to have a
copy of the local repository stored on
the service on the website itself get
provides command line tools that allow
you to interact with your files whereas
git help has a graphical interface that
allows you to check in and check out
files so let me just show you the two
tools here so here i am at the git
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do version control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with github there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to github git lab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as microsoft
visual studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of visual studio team services
also provides this same ability but
github it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to github and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment i'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact i think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on github at the moment that
number is probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project i would certainly encourage you
to start at github to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in github
certainly if you're doing anything with
azure you'll find that there are
thousands 45 000 azure projects
currently being worked on interestingly
enough github was recently acquired by
microsoft and microsoft is fully
embracing open source technologies so
that's essentially the difference
between get and github one is a piece of
software and that's git and one is a
service that supports the ability of
using the software and that's github so
let's dig deeper into the actual git
architecture itself so the working
directory is the folder where you are
currently working on your get project
and we'll do a demo later on where you
can actually see how we can actually
simulate each of these steps so you
start off with your working directory
where you store your files and then you
add your files to a staging area where
you are getting ready to commit your
files back to the main branch on your
git project you will want to push out
all your changes to a local repository
after you've made your changes and these
will commit those files and get them
ready for synchronization with the
service and will then push your services
out to the remote repository an example
of a remote repository would be github
later when you want to update your code
before you write any more code you would
pull the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure that that a the code remains at
very high quality and b that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning and get so
both of these terms are quite old terms
when it comes to development but forking
is certainly a term that goes way way
way back long before we had distributed
cvs systems such as the ones that were
using with git to fork a piece of
software is a particular open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entirety a
clone and this is important when it
comes to working with git a clone is
identical with the same teams and same
structuring as the main project itself
so when you download the code you're
downloading exact copy of that code with
all the same security and access rights
as the main code and then you can then
check that code back in and potentially
your code because it is identical could
potentially become the main line code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with git
you can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly where
you have large teams this works really
well when you have product teams where
the teams themselves are self-empowered
you can do a concept what's called
branching and get and so say for
instance you are working on a new
feature that new feature and the main
version of the project have to still
work simultaneously so what you can do
is you can create a branch of your code
so you can actually work on the new
feature whereas the rest of the team
continue to work on the main branch of
the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in services software the team is
working on from a remote server and get
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and re-establish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
branch will not be able to branch their
code back into the mainline branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and fork
the code that you're working on so let's
use this scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually go and you
can take the version of the mainline
branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainland branch it's now a
separate fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code i know i've
certainly made errors in my code it's
great to have other team members that
have your back and can come in and check
and see what they can do to improve the
code so to do that you have to then add
them as a collaborator now you do that
in github you can give them permission
within github itself it's really easy to
super visual um interface that allows
you to do the work quickly and easily
and depending on the type of permissions
you want to give them sometimes it can
be very limited permissions it may be
just to be able to read the files
sometimes it's being able to go in and
make all the changes you can go through
all the different permission settings on
github to actually see what you can do
but you'll be able to make changes so
that people can actually have access to
your repository and then you as a team
can then start working together on the
same code let's step through branching
and get so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
there can be many branches and get so
get keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process
so you're starting with the master
branch which is the blue line here and
then here we have a separate parallel
branch which has the new features so if
we're to look at this process the base
commit of feature b is the branch
f is what's going to merge back into the
master branch and it has to be said
there can be so many divergent branches
but eventually you want to have
everything merged back into the master
branch let's step through git rebase so
again we have a similar situation where
we have a branch that's being worked in
parallel to the master branch and we
want to do a get rebase so we're at
stage c and what we've decided is that
we want to reset the project so that
everything from here on out with along
the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch we'll be adding in new
features along this new re-based
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new master branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single master branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote suppose are two developers
working together on an application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers they're always working on the
latest code so you can pull any changes
that you have made to your forked remote
repository to your local repository the
command to be able to do that is written
here and we'll go through a demo of how
to actually do that command in a little
bit good news is if there are no changes
you'll get a notification saying that
you're already up to date and if there
is a change it will merge those changes
to your local repository and you get a
list of the changes that have been made
remotely so let's step through some of
the commands that we have in git so git
and it initializes a local git
repository on your hard drive git add
adds one or more files to your staging
area get commit dash m commit message is
a commit changes the get command commits
changes to head up so the git command
commits changes to your local staging
area get status checks the status of
your current repository and lists the
files you have changed get locked
provides a list of all the commits made
on your current branch get diff use the
changes that you've made to the file so
you can actually have files next to each
other you can actually see the
differences between the two files a git
push origin branch name so the name of
your branch command will push the branch
to the remote repository so that others
can use it and this is what you would do
at the end of your project get config
global username or tell get who you are
by configuring the author name and we'll
go through that in a moment get config
global user email will tell get the
author of by the email id git clone
creates a get repository copy from a
remote source and get remote add origin
server connects the local repository to
the remote server and adds the server to
be able to push to it get branch and
then the branch name will create a new
branch for you to create a new feature
that you may be working on
git check out and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another branch git merge branch name
will merge a branch into the active
branch so if you're working on a new
feature you're going to merge that into
the main branch a get rebase will
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and get rebase or reapply commits on
top of another base tip and these are
just some of the popular get commands
there are some more but you can
certainly dig into those as you're
working through using get so let's go
ahead and run a demo using get so now we
are going to do a demo using get on our
local machine and github as the remote
repository for this to work i'm going to
be using a couple of tools first i'll
have the deck open as we've been using
up to this point
the second is i'm going to have my
terminal window also available and let
me bring that over so you can actually
see this and the terminal window is
actually running get bash as the
software in the background which you'll
need to download and install you can
also run git batch locally on your
windows computer as well and in addition
i'll also have the github repository
that we're using for simply learn and
already set up and ready to go all right
so let's get started so the first thing
we want to do is create a local
repository so let's go ahead and do
exactly that so the local repository is
going to reside in my development folder
that i have on my local computer and for
me to be able to do that i need to
create a drive in that folder so i'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so i'm actually going to be in
that folder before i actually create and
make the new folder so i'm going to go
ahead and change directory
and now i'm in the development directory
i'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and that's going ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
i'm going to move my cursor so that i'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that i'm in the hello world
folder i can now initialize this folder
as a get repository
so i'm going to use the get command init
to initialize
and let's go ahead and initialize that
folder so let's see what's happened so
here i have my hello world folder that
i've created and you'll now see that we
have a hidden folder in there which is
called dot get and we expand that we can
actually see all of the different
subfolders that git repository will
create so let's just move that over a
little bit so we can see the rest of the
work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt
in our folder so here is our hello world
folder and i'm going to go ahead and
using my text editor which happens to be
sublime
i'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there text hello world
and i'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if i go to my hello world folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt
file actually in the folder what's
interesting is if i select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and
select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can go and
actually add the readme file so let's go
ahead we're just going to select at git
add so the git command is add readme dot
txt so that then adds that file into our
main
project and we want to then commit those
files into the main repositories history
and so to that do that we'll hit the get
command commit and we'll do a message
in that commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and i can change this so we
can go
hello get
git is a very popular
version control
solution and we'll
we'll save that
now what we can do is we can actually go
and see if we have made differences to
the readme text so to do that we'll use
the diff command for get so we do get
deaf
and it gives us two
releases the first is what the original
text was which is hello world and then
what we have afterwards is what is now
the new text in green which has replaced
the original text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on github we already have one and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from github with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do dash and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we'll put in our username that we use
for
github in this instance we're using the
simply learn
dash
github account name
and under the github account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local github account with the remote
helloworld.getaccount
and we do that by using this command
from get which is our remote connection
and so let's go ahead and type that in
open this up so we can see the whole
thing so we can type in git
remote
add
origin
https
backslash backslash
github
dot com slash
simply learn
dash
github and you have to get this typed in
correctly when you're typing in the
location hello
dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit get push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote github
so i'm just going to bring up my
terminal window again and so let's
select git remote add origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github github.com
simply
learn
dash
github
slash
hello
world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master
gish so git
push
origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to github now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and fork a project from github and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the
fork tool that's actually available on
github let me show you where that is
located
and
here is our branching tool it's actually
changed more recently with a new ui
interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the fork's new http url address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now i'm
actually logged in with the default
primary account for this project so i
can't actually fault the project as i'm
working on the main branch however if i
come in with a separate id and here i am
i have a different id
and so i'm actually pretending i'm
somebody else i can actually come in and
select the fork option and create a fork
of this project and this will take just
a few seconds to actually create the
fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
uh created the fork
so you want to set clone or download
with this and so this is the
i select
they'll actually give me the web address
i can actually show you what that looks
like i'll open up my text editor
which doesn't correct
i guess that is correct
so i'm going to copy that
and
i can fork the project locally and clone
it locally i can change the directory so
i can create a new directory that i'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file so i can
now actually have multiple versions of
the same code running on my computer
i can then go into default content
and use the patchwork command
to actually
so i can create a copy of
that code that we've just created and we
call it that's a clone and we can create
a new folder that we're actually putting
the work in and we could for whatever
reason we wanted to we could call this
where folder patchwork and that would be
uh maybe a new feature and then we can
then paste in the url of the new uh
directory that has the forked work in it
and now at this point we've now pulled
in and created a clone of the original
content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer
so we can then develop our work
separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in
that separate branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
and we will do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
github name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes emerged into the master
branch now to do that you would create a
folder and then that folder in this
instance would be called test we would
then move our cursor into the folder
called test and then initialize that
folder so let's go ahead and do that so
let's call create a new folder and we're
going to first of all change our root
folder and we're going to go to
development
and we're going to create a new folder
we'll call it test and we're going to
move into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're gonna do file save as
this one's gonna be test
two
and now we're gonna commit those files
okay add
that kit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git
commit
dash m
files committed
make sure i'm in the right folder here i
don't think i was
and now that i'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and
commit
and it's gone ahead and edit those files
and so we can see the two files that
were created have been added into the
master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch
and call this one get branch
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file
three
into file save as
we'll call this one
test3.txt
and we'll go ahead and add
that file and to get
add
test3.txt
and
we're going to move from the master
branch to the test branch
git
check
out
test underscore
branch
i switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the tech in that
branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git
merge test underscore
branch
as
well we've already updated everything so
that's good so otherwise it would tell
us what we would be merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from master branch to test branch
so git
check out
test underscore
branch
and we can modify
the files the test3 file that we took
out
and
pull that file up
and we can
now
modify
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in
and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and
obviously it's the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
of the work is kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future
so let's switch to it back to our test
branch which i think we're actually on
we're going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into
our branch that we're working on so
we're going to go and select
get add
dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit
dash
a
dash m
adding
two new files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our master
branch we want to rebase the master
so we do get rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date we can go
[Music]
get
checkout
master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then
continue through and rebase the test
branch and then list all the files that
are all in the same area
so let's go
get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
hello and welcome to git commands my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today i am going to
cover few essential git commands and
walk you through a demonstration for
most of it i begin by installing a git
bash on the git client and configuring
it for its first time usage once i'm
done with configuring the git client i'm
going to spin up few repositories
locally and work on these repositories
using git commands once i'm happy with
my local changes i'm going to commit few
of them and then push these changes to a
git server of my choice for today's
demonstration i plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually i will cover few
topics regarding git branching and
merging because these two in my opinion
are the killer features of the git
distributed version control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed version control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before i jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like windows
all flavors of windows linux mac os and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code checking
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a gitlab and gitlab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i will register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it onto my account within my git
server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there let me now go
ahead and find my git bash for my
windows so that i can go ahead and
install it so i just type in get
client for
windows open up a browser and type in
for this the first one that i find as a
gui tool i don't need this gui client i
need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0 and this is a 64-bit version for
windows so i've got that downloaded let
me go ahead and find it and install this
exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
now i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i am using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get
version it sounds good say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands
everything looks good so
i ended up installing the git bash i can
go ahead with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
username and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular user name of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
a global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place
and let me create this git demo again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this ripple all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialized an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here when i was in the
folder the repository did not have
anything after this now when i say in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git init and
then i have not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so command
to add that is called git add i can
specify either the name of the file or i
can give a while character saying git
add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a kit commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
right i run the gate status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made into a
git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit
id or the commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first command is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i will create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go and click
on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two urls one is the https
url and the other one is the ssh url as
of now we do not have any ssh keys that
is set up so let me use this https url
to connect my local repository with the
repository on the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
git remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master so git push hyphen u upstream
linking origin master link the master
uh branch of my local repository with
the master branch on the server
repository and where is it going to push
it is going to push by default to an
origin and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server so let
me go back to my server and refresh this
page and see if all my commits have come
in
master master1.txt
if at all i see the commits there seem
to be two comments this is my first
comment this is my second comment and if
at all you notice each of this commit
comes with a hash key or a hash id which
contains the details of my commits in
this commit the files were added this
was a line that was added if you look at
the second commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i've
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i'll click on new
ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t i would say
git
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase i hope i remember it
correctly
all right
pretty good i have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh alright so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that i create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server i will
create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server all right i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me i don't really need
to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i will just say
git push to be on the safer side i would
say origin and master
it ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second commit it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all you
are creating a local repository you can
get into any of the folder which is not
a git repository and run this command
whenever you run this command a magical
folder by name dot kit gets created in
the folder and from that time onwards
git will start tracking any changes that
happen to that particular folder it also
creates a new repository and a branch by
default the branch that is created is
called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you done in terms of the files that got
changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message get
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all the status of the
files will be obtained using the git
status command git log will show you all
the commit history with the latest
history or the latest commit showing up
on top git add remote origin this
command is used whenever you want to
link any local repository to a server
and this is when you want to really push
a repository from the local to the
server for the first time git push
hyphen u origin and master this is the
command that you would use whenever you
want to push contents from the local
repository to the server git clone and
the url of the server this is the
command that you would run whenever you
have an existing repository on the
server and you want to make a fresh
clone or a fresh copy of that particular
repository onto your local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of git
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the chain that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two comments but possibly i want
to club them together along with some
other changes because whatever changes i
did did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
commits but a soft would ensure that the
file changes that were done as a part of
these two comments would still exist a
full remain so the command for that is
git reset hyphen f and soft which is the
snapshot that i want to get back to if
this is the commit that i want to get
back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if what i do a git
status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe
i'll open up a notepad and possibly
create a new file called m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
also get
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all these c2 and c3
and get into c4 and has pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
developer 1 wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3 in short
you're removing a commit but to remove a
commit you're adding a new commit and
this is why you're doing it because
there are a bunch of other people who
are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and were planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 over
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest command so if at all i see
the contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and let's say looking at the previous
use case that i mentioned i may want to
get rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert and the commit id
whatever i want to revert so if i want
to revert this
i copy this particular commit id
and bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this essentially what i'm trying
to do i'm trying to undo this particular
commit while i'm undoing this commit
what does git do it safely adds a new
commit and a part of this new commit it
unders whatever changes that were done
as a part of this comment so if i say
git revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was it as a part of this commit
actually is getting rid of this commit
c3 so if at all i see my files here
there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch
a complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any files in
it so let me create a few files on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this
save this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first command
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files so you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if at
all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is gate checkout
plr branch i've actually switched into
bangalore branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because i've
created a branch from my base branch
which is a master branch and when i
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put on the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address.txt so i see notepad
address dot text
we'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in some address
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.text which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is get
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this
address.text in it so let me go back to
git git checkout master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you are in
the master branch the
file that was there in the bangalore
branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address dot text when
i go back to my master branch i don't
see this bangalore branch
contents which is the address.txt
right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push hyphen u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch it looks good
it says new branch master is created so
if i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bankrupt branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by
merging i would want the changes that is
there as a part of the bangalore branch
to come back into my master branch so if
i go to get checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attach.tech
this is there only as a part of
bangalore branch now assuming that i'm
done with the changes from the banner
branch i want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back to my
master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it'll merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address.txt this file should appear
as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this
address.txt that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well
gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches
the branches master even if i'm in
master brands i should see this address
dot text that is there even if i'm in
the bangalore branch the content is all
same because we immerse these two
branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say git branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bangle
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen we
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we've done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the gate branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you would type in git check
out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command git
push hyphen u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed
onto the server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git branch hyphen av assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you are on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to deep dive into
what jenkins is and how it improves your
devops continuous integration
environments
so this is what we're going to be
covering in this session we're going to
cover what life is like before using
jenkins and the issues that jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your devops team then
specifically we'll deep dive into
features of jenkins and the jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before jenkins
let's see this scenario i think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in india you
may have another developer that's based
in the philippines and you may have
another team lead that's based in the uk
and another development team that's
based in north america so you're all
working at different times and you have
different amounts of code going into the
code repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with just
a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other
so let's jump into jenkins and see what
jenkins is and how it can address these
problems
so jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment
so there are two ways in which you can
do continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous
so the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification services into the build
environment so you're always running
cycles to test against your code
this is the power that jenkins provides
in continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created
now if on the continuous integration
server a test isn't passed then that
code gets sent back to the developer and
the developer can then make the changes
it allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all the
tests locally on their computer write
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service off
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be beyond just the standard ci test
so maybe there's a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with and maven and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environment and create your releases
very quickly so buildbots also written
in python and it does support parallel
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on java
projects that need to be built and test
then apache gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the java projects easier
for you to be able to test with api
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create a versioning of
your code is github and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by microsoft if you
are storing your projects in github then
you'll be able to use travis continuous
integration or travis ci and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects
and so finally we're covering jenkins
and jenkins is a central tool for
automation for all of your projects now
when you're working with jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called hudson hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became jenkins and it was
acquired by oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that oracle may potentially go with
hudson and so they created a hard fork
of hudson that they renamed jenkins and
jenkins has now become that open source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your ci
environment
so let's jump into some of those really
great features are available in jenkins
so jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as i mentioned for
the easy installation jenkins is a
self-contained java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including windows mac
os and unix you even run it on linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
jenkins really powerful for developers
and continuous integration teams and
your devops teams as a whole when you
have plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there
in addition to the plug-in architecture
jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure jenkins to fit in your
environment it's almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending jenkins not creating a
custom version of jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core foundation the
distribution and the nature of jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your ci environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the jenkins
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing at least you
should be doing you're committing your
code to a git server um or to an svn
server or a similar type of service so
in this instance you'll be using jenkins
as the place for you to commit your code
jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the jenkins environment assuming
everything past the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
jenkins and finally again ready to
deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or go
through a nightly build you're looking
at being able to commit your code and go
through this testing process and release
process continuously as an example
companies etsy will release up to 50
different versions of their website
every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within jenkins that allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
server such as maven to actually then
build the code
and every single stage that we have that
jenkins manages there are constant tests
so for instance if a build fails that
feedback is sent right back to the
developers so that they can then change
their code so that the build environment
can run effectively
the final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
scripts can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how jenkins can be
extended with plugins mavin and selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again is an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention uh
one piece of information around the
jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the master slave architecture
within jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the master slave
architecture within jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and
that remote source code repository could
be github or it could be
team foundation services or the new
azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that master
environment can then push out to
multiple other jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario over the
last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as tesla
where they are creating software to
manage their cars we see the same thing
with companies such as general motors
with their onstar program and ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities enhancements to be added to
the core software so bosch is a company
that specifically ran into this problem
and their challenge was that they wanted
to be able to streamline the
increasingly complex automotive software
by adopting continuous integration and
continuous delivery best practices with
the goal of being able to delight and
exceed the customer expectations of the
end user so bosch has actually used
cloudbees which is the enterprise
jenkins environment so to be able to
reduce them the number of manual steps
such as building deploying and testing
bosch has introduced the use of cloud
b's from jenkins and this is part of the
enterprise jenkins platform has
significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment
now the results have been tangible
previously it took three days before a
build process could be done and now it's
taken that same three-day process and
reduced it to less than three hours that
is significant large-scale deployments
are now kept on track and have expert
support and there is clear visibility
and transparency across the whole
operations through using the jenkins
tools
hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever i install it as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warf file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration all
the way in which i'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
homepage and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page you
will have to
accept the license agreement and there
are a bunch of installers that is okay
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i have just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if you're told i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running a war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed in cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time if there
are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have that woken
up no need to panic because they will
all get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary uh
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured the smtp details of my
personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configurations that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it get if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it will crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
managing let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these usernames
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now i don't want any triggers
for now i'll come back to this in a
while build the environment i don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know i just want to you
know run few things so that i kind of
complete this particular job so since
i'm on a windows box i would say execute
windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do i
would let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here
and then i need to build this job and
you would see some building stray out
here nothing is there as of now because
i've just put in a job i've not run it
yet all right so let me try to build it
now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in a build script pretty
much similar to second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got triggered
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and ensuring that people don't
do something unwarranted all right so
first things first let me go ahead and
install a plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin a little bit
of a confusing screen in my opinion
there's updates available installed in
advance as of now we don't have the
role-based plugin so let me go to
available it'll take some time for it to
get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and
i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
setup and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some rules and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the cia instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qa guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but i would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read um kind of a role
credentials again i would just want to
view kind of a rule i don't want him to
create any agents and all that stuff
that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read through things i would
not give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
now check you know i have read only
access to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer and i'm
giving him very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so i would save
now i created a rule
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here house configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer one i would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role i want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer i would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular global rule and i would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qa person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket bitbucket is one of the git
servers there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all you
are looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plugin that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect jenkins build you can build
a job on jenkins and push it to sonar
cube and get sonar cube to run analysis
on that and get back the results in
jenkins all of these works very well
because of the plugins now with that let
me connect our jenkins instance to
github i already have very very simple
java repository up on my github instance
so let me connect jenkins to this
particular github instance and pull out
a job that is put up there all right so
this is my very very simple uh you know
repository that is there called hello
java and this is what is there in the
repositories hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there it's got just
one line of system dot out so this is
already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the url for this
repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is java and however run
my java file i would say java and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job it will be
a freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github and then what would be
there as a part of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and
you can you can build a war file and
even deploy it into some other server
for now what we're going to use maven is
just for building and creating a package
out of this particular web application
it contains a bunch of things and what
is important is just the index.jsp it
just contains an html file that is there
as a part of this web application so
from a perspective of requirements now
since i'm going to connect jenkins with
this particular repository git we
already have that set we only need two
other things one is maven because
jenkins will use maven so in order to
use maven jenkins would have to have a
maven installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple uh web server that you
can freely download i'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the tomcat all right so download maven
first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip mav1 just set this m2
home variable to the directory where you
unzip your i1 also just set the path to
this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and um
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
okay my tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and uh let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder i would see
this web application war file that is
already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify the
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is mn web
use the deployer deployment credentials
and get into this local host which is
there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you've got
to go and change is the url of the
server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough the
whole bundle or the war file that was
built as a part of this jenkins job gets
transferred onto the other server and
gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
the four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on docker
images docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
command to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you take the script that you've written
about the docker container that you
defined and push it to the repository
and as you can imagine the commands for
that are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write docker push the
image name any associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a docker image
that's using the build commands a docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a docker container and once a docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a docker hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be taking you through the
installation process for docker so
before we begin let me give you an intro
to docker so what is docker docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so when i say
containers i mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
docker on an ubuntu system so this is my
system i'll just open the terminal so
the first thing you can start with is
removing any docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these software is
on my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull an image
from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously too
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
and with that we come to an end of our
docker installation welcome everyone to
our one another demo on which we are
going to see that how exactly we can do
the installation of docker on the
windows platform specifically on windows
10. now docker is something which is
available for most of the operating
systems different different platforms so
it supports both the unix and the
windows platform as such so um linux
through various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker hub
websites you can simply google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the chrome and try to
search on for the windows string uh
particular installer you will get a link
from docker hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for windows so
you can go for this table or you can go
for the edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right so um
the particular edge version is something
which is getting releases every month
and uh the um stable version is getting
the releases every quarter so they are
not doing much of the changes to the
stable version as compared to the edge
there so you just have to double click
on the installer and that will help you
to do the installation of the process so
let's get started so you just click on
the get instable version so when you do
that the particular installer is going
to install now it's going to take like
around 300 mb there so that's the kind
of installed which is available so once
the installer is downloaded so what you
can do is that you can actually go ahead
and you can uh proceed with the doing
the double click on this installer when
you double click on that you have to
proceed with some of the steps like you
know from the gui itself you are going
to proceed with these steps so we'll
wait for 10 to 20 seconds more and then
the installer will be done and then we
can do the double click and the
installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binaries
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the hue size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as a docker desktop with the new
docker windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads
and here still we have some particular
installations or some download going on
so we'll wait for some time and uh once
the installation is done then we'll go
back and we'll proceed with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add the desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here the docker is
you know something which is installed so
you can run like docker version you will
be able to get a version of the client
when you do the restart of the machine
then at that moment of time the docker
server will also be started and then
this particular error message will go
off right now the docker daemon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a docker installation and we can go
on that part welcome everyone to this
topic on docker tutorial for the
beginners here now in this one we are
going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker
architecture of docker components of
docker game
so these are the different things which
we are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly isn't
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user
so it's a combination or collaboration
between the two teams development and
operations which helps us to go for a
further implementation of various
processes like continuous integration
continuous deployment continuous
delivery all these things are possible
with this collaboration over here now
why exactly docker is important for us
as such
in a city far away from this one so
a developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
vm uh it's not able to take up that much
kind of load over there so in order to
avoid this situation how exactly he can
do the various options or what he can
implement to have this uh issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications uh
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so
uh there will be no issues as such when
we talk about that uh the errors or the
uh virtual machines can not be crashed
and but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged component which can take up
any kind of load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker instead of the
virtual machine here the very first one
is the memory users so docker is having
a very less memory uses because there is
no concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram uh resources in order to keep
that particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
uh if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
up time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time
the performance everything is better in
case of docker as compared to the
virtual machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that one f2 and f3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
uh 3gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4gb
of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app 2 is using like
2gb and then you can see that the
specific 2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb
is occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that you know 9gb
of ram is used and the remaining 6 gb of
uh unused ram can not be used here
because if for example i allocate like 4
gb of ram to the virtual machine it's
there itself it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay
i'm using only 4gb ram out of this
9gb of ram then the next
5 gb of ram will be totally wasted so
you cannot reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine
if you are not using that much uh
resources or that much memory the
remaining memory will be simply wasted
because this is hardcorely allocated to
the virtual machine and you cannot
utilize this unused memory as such over
there so this is the limitation from the
memory perspective but in case of docker
definitely if uh you know out of the 9gb
of ram if we are using uh only 3gb of
ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using
out of 9gb if you're using 1gb 2gb 3gb
or 4gb whatever the remaining
memory is available that you can simply
use it for the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite
efficient in terms of memory when we
compare it with the virtual machine next
one is a performance now um in a virtual
machine we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here
so the guest operating system is also
going to take some particular resources
and
for example memory or a space
processor so in every terms in every
source terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the uh particular some of the
resources now problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you're just using
some small very small resources for your
application in an uh real world so
docker container on the other hand does
not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessarily wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and uh it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes on modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed in
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever container prepared in
the lower environment in a dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is a boot up time so uh the
boot up time of the virtual machines is
in minutes and whereas the boot up time
of the
docker containers is in
seconds or probably in milliseconds so
these are the reason why we consider the
virtual machine as an resources
based
environment but on the other hand docker
is something which is quite light and
fast as compared to virtual machines so
let's see that what exactly is in docker
all about here so in this one you can
see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have the host
operating system now we don't have the
hypervisor and the guest operating
system instead of that we have the
docker engine which is taking care of
managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in docker
container here now docker container is a
lightweight software package that uh
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a base operating system uh some
framework some for libraries it's it's
something which is a part of this one so
that if you will be
if you want to host your application you
will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers
now
within this docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
this docker containers you can host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability
and security over here now there are
different ways in which we can
understand the
benefits or we can have the
understanding about the
docker here
so uh these are some couple of
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so
it's it supports the rapid deployment
now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to website so there are
some couple of steps which needs to be
done across different different
environments like for example if i have
five environments i have to do the
deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the uh quick and easy configurations so
the configurations of docker containers
is quite easy you can have your own
custom docker images built out the
docker files so these processes can be
integrated within the jenkins also so
cicd is quite possible with the help of
docker if you want to really do that and
then we have better efficiency yes they
have a better efficiency and reduce
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability uh we have
already thought about that that it's
easy to move from one environment from
one system to another in fact it's easy
from the developer also so from one
machine from one developer to another
developer it's very easy to move these
uh different docker containers then we
have scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools
then security is there so
you can have your best practices of the
security implemented because um it's
just a kind of a virtualization just
like a virtual machine so you have all
the uh different uh possibilities which
is available which you can explore when
you talk when you want to make this
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and uh whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the ubuntu part operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the mac operating system so for mac
operating system you have the dmg files
and when you do the dmg file so it will
uh help you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view
wants to do the installation of that
particular component
now next one is the architecture of
docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say the docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user
and it will send those particular things
or the requirements to the docker daemon
to the server using the rest api
interface so this docker daemon is
something which keeps on running on the
server and it's a background process it
gets deployed as in service there in
case this docker demon is not available
or it's not up and running you will not
get the proper response from the docker
command line here so in order to get all
your activity or your
procedures implemented you need to have
the docker server or docker daemon up
and running in fact this docker cli can
be configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli company uh like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
uh going to take up all the requests
from the end user then um it's using the
rest api interface which is there to
have the connectivity with the docker
demon so docker daemon is something
which is always up and running so if you
run couple of commands like docker pull
push and also that activity you are
actually sending the request to the
docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's it's the
same process across all the
infrastructure all the different
platforms whether you use mac operating
system you use windows or you use linux
everywhere this is the basic
functionality and it keeps on listening
to the rest api interface so uh whatever
the request new request comes in it
immediately process it and whatever the
response whether you are stopping a
container whether you are running a
container according to that the action
will be taken and the response will be
sent back to the rest api to the docker
client so a docker is a process or it's
a command line which is used to start
the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that docker is the process or is
the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psiphony f
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
particular docker registry so we have a
ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images uh
on these docker registry so there are a
lot of ready-made uh docker images which
is available there but of course you can
have your own uh docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom uh registry docker registries
also for example in jfrog you can have
your private hosted registries also so
all these are different repositories you
can use with your docker container so
docker containers is having the
flexibility that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final dock container so docker image
is uh nothing but uh for example i want
to have a tomcat apache docker image so
what are the instructions i have to do
so the very first thing is that i have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that i will be installing the
jdk or some prerequisite packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the tomcat apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the uh activity we
will be able to have a docker container
ready which we can deploy to host tomcat
apache so it's a template which is
having all the uh particular
instructions in order to build a docker
image you require a file called
dockerfile which is uh of course having
all these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the dockerfile it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get a end result uh
then uh these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of of the tomcat apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in uh component which is
available and these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that there
are four instructions and these four
instructions are also known as the four
layered docker image so whatever the
final docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
uh the docker image here now the very
first is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are
pulling up and then we are pulling like
uh the file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot
python file over here in this one so
these are four instructions which is
available right so uh which will
definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one to one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this ways you have
you can see that the previous docker
file which we processed so the base
layer is ubuntu 18.04 we are not
building that actually it's
automatically so it's by default getting
downloaded as in full base layer after
that only we have like layer 1 layer 2
layer 3 added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the
containers layers so one two one the
very first instruction does not
comprises it it is it's not a kind of a
container layer we can call it as an
base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer one may
be having some different of
instructions layer two maybe having
different instructions so like that it's
a
step-by-step processor
in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted over
there in that one so if i delete some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
suppose having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers so whenever
we uh perform any activity or whenever
copy on uh right strategies and strategy
to share and copy files for better
efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and
it definitely reduces the overall disk
utilization and this is very important
also because when you have so many
docker containers up and running so you
have to worry or you have to make the
utilization of a disk or your disk users
or resources also minimum so that is
also you need to make sure that it does
not exceed a particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these layers are combined and got a
final product or called a you know you
can call it as docker image or docker
containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a write table
which is known as copy on right so copy
and write strategy is being used so to
do the changes or to do the perform the
modifications of this union file system
by creating the different different
layers
so
now let's talk about the docker registry
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the
tool where you can share these images
definitely it's not easy for you to port
these docker images from one system to
another so docker register is very
important for the portability feature of
docker so docker registry is a service
to host and distribute docker images
among users so uh it can be built up by
one user and multiple users can use it
for example i'm using a jenkins one so
um jenkins uh image is prepared only
once but it's being used by different
people as such docker registry uh again
it's a repository is a collection of
docker images so in a repository you
will be having like different different
uh docker images as such so in registry
a user can distinguish between the
docker images with their tag names so uh
for example jenkins is an a kind of a
single image they might be different
type of images there let's say that okay
let's talk about uh jenkins uh jdk so
there will be image called jenkins the
name of the image will be same but the
tags will be different so one tag could
be like jdk8 one tag would be like jtk9
and one time would be dedicated so the
difference between all these three
docker images is that that jdk 81 is
prepared on jdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jdk9 in that case
you have to pull down the the darker
image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguished
between the
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and docker by default is having its own
uh cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure so in
that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories on
the uh specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these docker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the uh docker hub so
when you run some build process or when
you run the containers there may be some
docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available definitely pull command will
be successful but in case of push
command you are pushing your custom
docker images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the
application source code inside it so the
docker container don't have to look for
the dependencies on the host machine on
the server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system everything is inside
the docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines so whatever works on one system
can be easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having
your application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
docker container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interference so they share the os called
uh kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that the containers to have the
interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
uh capability over here that you know if
the there is some unused uh space that
can be easily shared across the multiple
containers here so uh it is uh built
using the docker images so
using the docker images the docker
containers are built up and docker run
is a specific command which is used to
build a docker container so if you got a
docker image let's say that i have
prepared a docker image a custom docker
image using the docker file now if i
need to create a docker container out of
a docker image i have to run a docker
turn command so docker run command is
nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now next
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships everything is inside this
docker file here so you want to run two
containers that's totally fine instead
of running two commands now you just
have to run one file and that will do
take care of that now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any um manual
activity or without any maintenance onto
the server
so uh these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format and in this you define
that okay i need two containers and this
in this image should be there these are
the parameters which you need to run and
if you want to have the interaction or
the linkage between the images that also
you can establish within this yml file
or this in within this docker compose
file here right so let's say for example
i want to have an application which
requires apache web server and mysql
database now uh i can create a docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and mysql containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swamp is a
inbuilt or it's a default
uh orchestration tool which is being
provided by the docker itself it's a
service for containers which allows the
id administrators and the developers to
create and manage a cluster of smart
nodes so um in a typical world when you
do the installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple uh instances
or scalability all these things are not
possible as it is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like talker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
five six known machines are there on
which you can have your highly available
application infrastructure implemented
now this one means that if i want to run
my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swim is having a
docker daemon
which is uh used to for performing the
interaction so there will be a master
node which is available so uh it will be
interacting with all the known machine
on the all the client machines and this
interaction will be in such a way that
it will let them know okay i want to
deploy the
container or onto the node 3 so it will
perform that activity and the container
will be up and running on the node 3
there so a swamp consists of two type of
nodes one is the manager node and one is
the worker node so manager is the master
node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes
you can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can uh do during the deployment
of the containers so manager will will
keep on connecting to the different
worker nodes there and whenever new
request comes in so it will basically
try to connect and see that okay i just
want to go ahead and deploy a container
so it will do the deployment of the
container on the worker node so the main
work will be done by the worker nodes
and manager is just doing the management
of all these resources the worker nodes
will be definitely receiving the request
from the manager and uh it will be
proceeding and performing those
activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a docker image using a docker file on
the open220 so uh you want to use a base
operating system as an ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so uh let's take an operating
system of ubuntu 20 20 is the latest
version of the one two operating system
so i have got a server so let's see so
first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen world so that is going to pull a
darker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu uh docker image also
if you feel that you want to try you can
do that but the main uh demo which we
need to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu base operating system
on top of that we will be installing php
engine x all these different components
so we are going to have a php based
website hosted onto the apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that i just create a particular
folder called nginx iphone image and
then i create a docker file over there
so docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity
now uh what we can do is that uh what uh
we have got a server over here now in
this server what i'm going to do is that
i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers so
i have got a particular container over
here so what i can really do is that i
can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so
i'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to
establish the fact that i'm trying to
connect i'm trying to uh connect with
the 0.2 url so that at any moment of
time i should be able to fetch on the
latest packages now once that is done so
i'm going to run the command called apt
install docker dot io now the moment i
do this what will happen that it will
try to download some packages it will
ask for the confirmation you can give
your confirmation and i can say yes the
moment you give the confirmations the
download of the packages will proceed
over here step by step it will download
the packages and the installation will
go on now once the installation is done
so what you can do is that you can see
that docker is deployed into your system
or not you can run docker version
command or you can also use the service
command to check to make sure to ensure
that the docker service is always up and
running if the service is not up and
running you have to make sure you have
to enable it you have to start that
service so these are some couple of
steps which you need to do in order to
make sure that your connectivity or your
environment is ready for with the docker
installation and once the docker
installation is done then only you will
be able to proceed further with the
further activities like preparing the
containers preparing the images and all
that stuff but if you don't have the
docker installed prior to that then
definitely it's going to be a problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of uh steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that
it will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response
and uh now you can see that it's showing
up that a process is running so earlier
it was not uh up and running it was
inactive but now it's active and you can
see here that dark ride is the process
which is running over here as an uh
process to initialize the docker daemon
so docker demon is up and running now
and we are good to go here so now uh if
we go and say like docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker demon and docker demand is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that uh yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run
iphone it
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a ubuntu docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some uh process or i want to perform
some activity i should be able to
connect to that docker image so the
moment i do this first of all if this
docker image is available locally that's
great it will immediately create the
container if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the docker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see it shows that
root at the id uh root and the rate one
id is there this id is nothing but it's
a container id which we are getting here
so definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run docker ps hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you ran
hello world you ran the one to one both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit 0 in the status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to
go ahead to the level where we need to
create a custom docker image and do the
setup accordingly so let's see that how
we can do that now i'm going to create a
particular folder called nginx hyphen
image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called docker
file so let's see that what content we
need to put as such when you talk about
the docker file because whatever content
you put over here that is what according
which the docker image will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay 0.220.04 is what i want to use
then we are giving some labels now these
labels are used to give some information
like uh what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so uh
these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh docker file or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to uh set up a parameter
like deviant underscore printed as in
non-interactive because whenever we talk
about any build process in dockerfile it
it cannot be there in the interactive
session it should be there in the
non-interactive and definitely a typical
uh scenarios like you can run app update
command and then we are installing the
php engine x super supervisor all these
things we are doing we are doing the
installation uh we are using the run
attribute run a particular step and in
there whatever the commands are executed
these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so nginx we are virtual host php
underscore conf engineering centers for
conf and supervisor underscore conf
these are the different environment
variables which we configuring over here
now next thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from our linux
server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statement so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore conf and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are saying
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then we
are uh you know creating some folder
structure we adw html folder structure
we are creating so that we will be able
to push some content over there and then
we have the volume configurations so
whatever the volume configurations are
there we are putting up so that um you
know we will be able to have all the
specific direct directories mounted on
the host machine on the whole server so
that we can even talk about locally also
and then the star.search is something
which we need to run because that's uh
that will go into the command statement
which needs to be executed because when
you want to run your process when you
want to run your engine x process or
your docker container some process
should be up and running that's where uh
if any interactive process will run then
only the docker container will be hold
up so that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together
till the exposed part that's where we
come up into these one so expose we are
doing 80 and 443 over here
right after this one we have to create
the uh host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the star.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that uh so this is what i
will my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands uh these
are the environment variables i'm using
then further on these variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the
host machine from the server to the
docker container and then second file is
super wiser d not con file and then we
have star dot sh file so these are the
different files which we want to
configure here so once this file is
prepared we have to uh type in or we
have to create a default file over here
in this current directory so in this
current directory we have to put up a
file called default now in this one we
will be having the default virtual host
configuration config so we need to put
our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and
put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and uh then we have a supervisor dot com
file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisor
file
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into a docker
file so
we can double check that
so once this is done
save it
and we can check the docker file you can
grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that's
cool so we got default we got supervisor
d now we have to create the star dot sh
file because in this one we will be
configuring that how we want to start
our process of this nginx or this web
server so in this one again we have to
run the uh supervised process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised
config also available so that's also
there and the moment is done so you are
going to give the execute permission to
this one because uh you can see that
into our docker file that we are having
the attribute where we want to run this
into the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case so that uh change
mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here now
once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular uh components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know
got docker file super isd.conf default
all these files are there now the only
thing which we need to do next is that
we need to build to the build process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process so what happens the docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh nginx iphone image is the name which
you want to refer now you can totally
use this uh custom name you whatever
name you feel that you want to use you
can always use that there's no
restriction on that part and once that
is on so you will be able to list down
those images that you got a new custom
docker image here so you can see that
you got the ubuntu as a base image which
is built down and the nginx iphone image
is also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and you can
run the docker run command to see that
if you really got connected with that
particular one so let's go back and uh
see that how we can create
the docker custom docker image here so
the moment i do this so it will pick up
the docker file over here and start
performing the activities uh the package
installations all those configurations
ones will be performed over here in a
non-interactive mode there is no
confirmation which will be asked from
the user because you cannot put that
confirmations so the command should be
in such a way that it should not take
any kind of confirmations at all from
the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the
confirmations during the execution so so
it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed and um
here we go so we caught the successful
message now you can see it says
successfully tag this one this means
that there is no issues at all with the
docker image and when you run the docker
images or docker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 mb of the size
of this image that represents that this
docker image is fully ready to run to
execute
so now what we are going to do is that
we are going to map a volume over here
with the wwe html directory during the
execution of this container because i
really want to deploy some pages some
web pages there if you have the web
pages now as part of the build process
as part of the docker file you can do a
git clone also of some repository but i
don't want to do that uh during the
preparation of docker image i just now
got an environment where the nginx is
set up properly and it's up and running
there now it should be upon me that how
i want to put up my content and all so
that's the reason why i'm putting up a
kind of a folder structure over here and
sharing it with the docker container so
that the moment i put the
html files or the php files into that
local folder i should be able to get
some web page up and running there so
that's what i'm going to do over here in
this one so i'm going to create a folder
structure saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web root i will be putting up some files
and then same files will be redirected
inside the docker container with the
help of docker volume so let's go back
to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that uh you are going to connect on
that part okay so uh you can use this
port as an at also but here 880 is used
so whatever port you feel you want to
use you can do that and we are giving
the container name as test an iphone
container that also you can change nginx
hyphen image is the one which we are
using so if you use some different uh
particular image you can also use that
and uh you can see that the webroot is
something which we are connecting with
the wear www html directory so the
moment you put some file in the web
route the same file will be reflected
into the
ww html directory there so i'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the html one so i'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now i'm
going to copy that command
okay and hit on so if the at port is
used so you have to make sure that photo
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
port you're using that should be free
now when you run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running but if you see
like docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker ps command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
and test hyphen container is the name
now you got a container up and running
so you can actually do a call on
localhost colon 8080 so um this is a way
to get the content
you can get the public ip also and uh in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now uh
we are getting the response at least uh
it's showing his 403 error forwarding
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the rwb html
directory or we can say in local web
root directory so that we will be able
to have some content so what we can do
is that we can have some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a uh you know couple of files so uh i'm
just using this echo command
so um
the moment i go for this execution so
what happens that a file will be created
into that uh slash web route there so um
i'm expecting that i have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and the moment you do the curl
now you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files you want to put up some
php content all that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content that
is going to help me to get a file so my
web root will have now two files so um
if if you feel
uh that index.html file should have some
meaningful content you can always do
that you can pull some of the websites
also you can put that into the you can
do a git clone in the web root and the
whole application will be started and uh
now
if you feel that i got a info.php file
so i can use the in that name into the
url i have to modify the url because
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting the output so this is the php
content output which is there it's a
complete information now it may look
like a very bulky content to you but
when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry it's showing in
the output and this output represents
that you got a particular php content
here so this is how we will be able to
have a container and uh you know this
container is up and running you can
modify to at any level you feel that you
want to prepare a darker image with the
code embedded also uh you can have the
clone or you can have this configuration
into some git repository have the source
code also there and then prepare a
complete bundle altogether so this is
what we have in this demo how we can
deploy a container and a container up
and running in case of the docker here
today we're going to cover what is a
docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat in a
with java a second container is running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host os which could
be linux it really could be any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a tester now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times and this is where
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environments if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the jboss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from the challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docker container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go at through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is docker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer a
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest api connection
to a docker daemon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker daemon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest api and that sends
command line to the docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with darker the docker
demo then checks the request against and
the docker components and then performs
the service that you're requesting now
the docker image itself all it really is
a collection of instructions used to
create a container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the actual
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
can kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
solutions the actual docker registry
itself is an environment for being able
to host and distribute different docker
images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in
the container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer intended what's interesting
though is the actual applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications that's
using dependencies on other libraries or
files outside of the container because
of the architecture it really uses a lot
less space and because it's using less
space it's a much more lightweight
architecture so the files the actual
folder itself is much smaller it's very
secure highly portable and the boot up
time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other doc images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private um repository
so you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command
so if you want to get a image from a
docker registry then you want to use the
pull command and a pull command simply
pulls the image from the registry and in
this example using nginx as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our docker
application on our local machine we're
able to then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the run command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just a you know a few
uh interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layers called the container
layer each container has a separate read
write container layer and any changes
made in that docking container is then
reflected upon the particular container
layer and if you want to delete the
container layer the container layer also
gets deleted as well so you know why
would using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jboss at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask is you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we'll end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a docker container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands in the demo that we're going to
do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stop working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac and we're going to go ahead
and the first thing we want to do is see
what our docker image lists are so we
can go sudo docker images and this will
give us well first we'll enter in our
password so let's go enter that in and
this will now give us a list of our
docker images and here are the docker
images that have already been created in
the system and we can actually go ahead
and actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and open up this window a little
bit more but this will show you the
actual processors and the containers
that we actually have and so on the far
left hand side you see under names we
have learn simply learn the underscore
cool these are all just different ones
that we've been working on so let's go
ahead and create a docker image so i'm
gonna do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash p
0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80.
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
some there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit state and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
dash i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is gonna be the new container
name it's gonna be my docker so this is
how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and dashbin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my and we'll get the container image
which will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you actually see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created that's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this says grab this one and we'll put it
in rename and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo
docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image it's just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my ducker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command so sudo
docker
rm
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right
let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of the
container that we actually have
so pseudo
docker
kill
oh we're gonna list out the ones they're
running oh okay there we go now yellow
isn't in that list so let's take i know
let's take simply learn and so we can
actually go ahead and let's write sudo
docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container hey everyone welcome to
this simply learn video on cubanity's
full course in this full course we will
learn everything about communities in
detail we will begin this full course
video with understanding what exactly is
kubernetes is next we will see how to
install kubernetes and the differences
between kubernetes and docker then we
will look into the services and
components of kubernetes in detail after
that we will be discussing everything
about the architecture of kubernetes
then we will see how communities can be
implemented on aws finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
important kubernetes interview questions
and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates by the end of
this video i can assure you that all
your communities career related queries
will have been answered
so let's start with an exciting video on
the configuration management tool before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simplylearn
hello and welcome to simplyline in this
session we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you would want to
be using it within your devops team but
before we get started remember to hit
the like button if you like this video
and the subscribe button if you want to
get notified about more of these videos
as they come out and as always if you
have any comments about content that
we're covering or questions that you
have on the subject please post them in
the comments below so let's get started
we're gonna break up this presentation
into four key areas we're gonna talk
about life before kubernetes which some
of you are probably experiencing right
now what is kubernetes the benefits that
kubernetes brings to you particularly if
you are using containers in a devops
environment and then finally we're going
to break down the architecture and
working infrastructure for kubernetes so
you understand what's happening and why
the actions are happening the way that
they are so let's jump into our first
section of life before kubernetes so the
way that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now
it's really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to buying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be
problems with resource allocation and
you're going to have area issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not not effectively and not load
balance um effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure is that
it gets very expensive uh you can only
install one piece of software one
service on one piece of hardware so your
hardware is being massively under
utilized this is where virtual machines
have become really popular with a
virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability at much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware the problem is is that vms or
for virtual machines are not perfect
either some of the challenges you run
with vms is that the actual hardware and
software need needed to manage the vm
environment can be expensive there are
security risks with virtual with vms
there are security risks with vms there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions in the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up and
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
um and this is largely because of the
legacy code uh the legacy of kubernetes
and where it came from we will talk
about that in just a moment but
kubernetes is inherently secure virtual
machines are not easily portable now
with that said they they are technically
portable they're just not very easily
portable whereas with kubernetes it's
working with docker container solutions
it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a
virtual machine a few other areas that
we want to kind of highlight from
differences virtual machines use much
less isolation when building out the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does for instance with a virtual machine
you have to run hypervisor on top of the
os and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hierarchy so as we highlighted here vms
are not as portable as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment because it allows
the infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open source platform that is allows
you to manage and deploy and maintain
groups of containers and the container
is something like docker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using docker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple docker
environments together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around uh kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
google board um google borg it does
exactly what kubernetes and does today
but kubernetes was rewritten from the
ground up and then released as an open
source project in 2014 so that people
outside of google could take advantage
of the power of kubernetes
containerization management tools and
today it is managed by the cloud native
computing foundation and there are many
many companies that support and manage
kubernetes so for instance if you're
signing up for microsoft azure aws
google cloud all of them will leverage
kubernetes and it's just become the the
de facto tool for managing large groups
of containers so let's kind of step
through some of the key benefits that
you'd experience from kubernetes and so
we have nine key benefits and the first
it is highly portable and is 100 open
source code and this means that you can
actually go ahead and contribute to this
code project if you want to through
github uh the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible um what's um the
the history of kubernetes being part of
a google project for managing the google
network and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the
load balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud first environment
um kubernetes as well is that it's it's
really a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails uh
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated rollouts
and drawbacks in case you need to be
able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes um that actually are running
on linux machines um outs that are
controlled by the master so let's kind
of go through some of these um areas so
i would look at the kubernetes master
and to begin with um then we'll start
with uh etc this is a tool that allows
for the configuration of information and
the management of nodes within your
cluster and one of the key features that
you'll find with all of the tools that
are managed within either a the master
environment or within a node is that
they are all accessible via the api
server and what's interesting about the
api server is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with ssl
and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the uh the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas controller is the
management actually pushes out all of
the controls via the api server so let's
actually dig into um one of the actual
nodes themselves and there are three key
areas of the nodes one is the dark
environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in structure to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way hi guys in today's video i am going
to show you how to install ubuntu on
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose y
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system cto enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
code
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo chmod command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubedium cubectel and
kubernetes cmi so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap of
hyperlink
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm in it this is going to take a
few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so
moving forward
the next step is to deploy paths using
the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the pods you have to
use the command sudo cubic till get bots
there you can see the paws that have
been deployed hello and in this video
we're going to cover a common
conversation which is kubernetes versus
daca but before we jump into that i want
you to hit the subscribe button so you
get notified about new content as it
gets made available and if you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simply learn in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus darker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through um a
number of solutions they ended up coming
up with a solution of having kubernetes
running their iot platform as a service
inside of amazon's aws cloud service and
what you'll see with both these products
is they're very cloud friendly but here
we have um bose and kubernetes working
together with aws to be able to scale up
and meet the demands of their product
catalog and so the result is that we
were able to increase the number of
non-production deployments significantly
by taking the number of services from
being large bulky surfaces down to small
microservices being able to handle as
many as 1250
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge
that
paypal was
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
fifty percent increase in availability
for being able to
add in additional time for building
testing and deploying of applications
just a huge win for paypal now let's dig
into kubernetes and docker so kubernetes
is an open source uh platform and it's
designed for being able to maintain a
large number of containers and what
you're gonna find is that your argument
for kubernetes versus docker isn't a
real argument it's kubernetes and docker
working together so kubernetes is able
to manage the infrastructure of a
containerized environment and docker is
the number one container management
solution and so with docker you're able
to automate the deployment of your
applications being able to keep them in
a very lightweight environment and being
able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated uh
the configuration for docker is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two
and the differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers uh so the the
difference
here is that kubernetes is going to
manage the entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of pods
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers that can
control the services that actually power
the applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas a docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now i'm not going to
kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
it's if of the tools that you're going
to be using in your devops environment
it's it's not an easy setup for you to
use and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the the services
within its own containers what you'll
find is that most public cloud providers
will provide support for both kubernetes
and docker here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick to jump on and support kubernetes
but the reality is is that today google
amazon and many other providers are
having first level support for
kubernetes it's just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
docker is fast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list hello and welcome
to simply learn today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we'll do a
deep dive into the actual kubernetes
architecture itself and how kubernetes
runs and operates within your network
and then finally we're going to look at
some kubernetes use cases of how you can
actually apply best learnings that other
companies have used with kubernetes
we'll finish everything off with a demo
where we actually step through and use
some of the actual codes that you can
actually use to run uh from your
terminal window to actually activate
kubernetes itself so with that said
let's jump in so why kubernetes well
kubernetes is really being built from
allowing you to be able to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers you
have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very easy to be able to maintain
and to be able to scale and meet the
demands that your current customers are
offering you today the actual ability
for you to be able to deploy and update
software at scale is really at the heart
and center of kubernetes it's really one
of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers uh
within a data center and then finally uh
when you start working with kubernetes
really what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by google google actually uh
used the precursor to kubernetes to
manage and maintain the
data structure and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allowed for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done uh kubernetes will
help you automate those manual processes
uh if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic rollback
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and docker often
get connected with each other largely
because kubernetes manages containers
and docker is really famous for creating
the most popular uh container management
solution which is called docker if
you're a developer you're probably
already using docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale just massive volume
of containers docker swarm is docker's
alternative to kubernetes it's a tool
that allows you to also manage large
number large numbers of containers um
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular um open source solution out
there is kubernetes from google it just
has a massive community behind it and uh
the community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by google but google
has been great steward and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you will be able to
set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com
youtube i mean just incredibly robust
environment compared to docker swamp
which has lower fault tolerance and and
this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee
strong clusters and management just a
really reliable environment dr swarm
however is able to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set uh in
contrast load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine
in a data center
or a virtual machine and when you're
setting up an environment on a cloud
environment such as microsoft azure or
google cloud or aws kubernetes will be
managing the containers within that node
so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment the actual
control of data within a cluster um it's
very very flexible within kubernetes you
can have local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a hardware
free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application that's within a container
and as mentioned earlier docker is the
most popular container solution out
there and again if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
will actually manage the containers that
you have within your nodes and so you
have a collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that part so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the pods
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
parts your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is
comprised of a number of key components
and again this is the tool that's going
to manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the etcd control manager
scheduler api server and the key four
components are etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored um in
the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and uh the instructions here are to pull
down the correct container from the
docker images that you have within your
library the cubelet is going to manage
your containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up and if you know any xml you'll
pick up yammer very quickly and finally
the kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and or even if you're just starting off
and doing some simple work in the cloud
there's a really good chance that you
are using kubernetes but some of the
companies that you would are probably
not surprised at using kubernetes are
spotify sap ebay
and of course some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a youtube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when new york times started working
after their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is that
they treated the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
data center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon and start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as a service um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual uh infrastructure
um updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take
our time to do a demo so we have six
terms that we're going to look through
um and uh we'll let you uh uh read
through these but uh we have a cluster
which is a set of machines physical or
vertical in which applications are
managed and run we have a node that are
the working machines that run
containerized applications and other
workloads there is the pod which is
within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a pod life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources labels are key value
pairs that are attached to objects such
as parts and the key value pair or the
label can be filter organize and perform
operations on resources replication sets
define how many replicas of each pod
will be running and managed when you
want to either replace a pod when it
dies annotation is a label with much
larger data capacity a name is a
resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top tier pods which
provide a single ip address and dns name
by which the pods can be accessed so
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
i'm going to take you through a video of
how to actually install kubernetes um
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
widely used platform for container
management the first step is to actually
install the necessary dependencies so
let's see if there's any updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we use the command sudo app dash
get update we're going to enter in our
password and this looks like it's going
to take a few minutes because we've got
a few updates that need to be running
all right we're done all right next
we're going to write sudo apt-get
installed
y apt
transport https and this will install
all the dependencies we need to actually
start installing the solutions needed
for kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go typo correct that
quickly and put in y so vs and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install docker off the internet and it's
quite a large installation now would be
a good time to go get a cup of coffee
because it'll take us about a minute to
get this all done once we actually have
docker installed we'll let you go ahead
and we'll start docker and enable docker
using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're going to use sudo system ctl start
docker and sudo system ctl enable docker
this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to
install the curl command and then
kubelet cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt we can say yes for
that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudo curl dash s
and then we have
long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
key dot gpg
sudo apt dash key there we go and create
my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of like folder so we do that
with sudo chmod
777 slash etc
apt apt
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
then the following command db http
apt
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes kubernetes.list and we'll
save that and then we can close out the
notepad and go back to the terminal
window and let's look and see if there
are any updates again so we're going to
go ahead and run apt-get update and it's
going to run any updates from what we've
created and we want to check what's in
the folder and so we do
cat slash accept
etc
ept sources dot
d slash kubernetes dot list and there we
are it shows what we have in that text
file and so we're gonna go ahead and
we're going to uh install uh cubelet
cubic cubic 2 and cube adm but first
we're going to have to initialize the
master i'm going to show you what an
error you would get if you were to
install cubelet um and the other files
too quickly you get the following error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubex tool and kubernetes cni and
so we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo kubu cube
ctl apply and then we have a long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content.com choreos final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating
mktr
p
and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot cube i'll
create that new directory and sudo cp
dash i and then the path will be
etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo
chow n dollar sign open bran id dash u
close paren colon dollar sign a brand id
slash dash g close paren dollar sign
home slash dot cube
config all right now we're going to go
ahead and deploy and uh let's see uh oh
yeah i think i have a typo in my command
here yep oh yeah i did have a typo and
so um i've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an s and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic uh cube ctl
apply uh
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
parts that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by uh writing the
command sudo
tcl uh get pods dash all dash dash name
spaces and it should list all of our
pods we only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we're going to use the command sudo you
know cubic tl get nodes there we are
just one node so our final step is to
actually go ahead and deploy a service
and so what we're going to go ahead is
deploy the nginx service and we're going
to do that with the command sudo cubex
ctl run dash dash image equals nginx and
we're going to put this into port 80. so
it's going to be nginx nash app dash
dash port equals 80
environment emd equals uh ubun cone open
quotes so domain equals cluster close
quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is pseudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx
http and once we've done this we will be
able to then run the command to actually
see our services and there'll be quite a
few of them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands um it it's worth going
through a few times to
get right um but
once you actually have um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your docker environment in
containers it's extremely powerful if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
welcome to kubernetes architecture from
simply land we're going to take a deep
dive into the kubernetes architecture if
you're new to kubernetes we already have
an introduction that goes and provides
an overview of kubernetes and we have
the link below so you can go straight to
that if you want to have a refresher
otherwise hang around and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification
right onto your phone or on your desktop
that the new video has been uploaded and
as always if you have any questions
please post them in the comments below
we do read the questions and we try to
respond to all of them as quickly as we
can with that said let's jump into
kubernetes architecture so we're going
to break out the presentation into the
following areas we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you want to
be using it we're going to introduce the
actual architecture and provide an
overview of how it contains the
containers and the other components that
you'd have within the architecture we'll
also compare kubernetes with docker
swarm and one of the things that you
hear with kubernetes almost in the same
um breath as darker and we have to be
careful not to confuse daca from a
container point of view and docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so compare the two of
those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by google out
of the google borg solution and then
open source by google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with docker then you're used to the
concept of the container and you'll also
know that containers and cloud
technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath so the work that
you're doing with kubernetes is to be
able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points uh kubernetes
itself is an open source solution
originally developed by google but it is
available on most cloud platforms today
so aws google cloud microsoft azure all
of them support kubernetes and what
you'll find is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these i think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down containers
into their smaller parts and once you do
that it becomes much more efficient for
you as an administrator to be able to
manage that entire entire environment
the reproductibility of kubernetes is
extremely high you can build up
infrastructures very quickly and um have
them being able to manage and have
containers coming on and off and killed
and uh created to be able to help low
balance your entire environment and so
again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed
by the master environment so you have
your cluster which is a collection of
servers that um maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as ram cpu and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule the
activities of your network and then you
have the node which actually hosts the
actual docker virtual machine itself um
and be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail in the architecture later in
the presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital technologies
over the last uh 10-15 years so
before kubernetes you had tools where
you're either running virtual machines
or you're running uh data centers that
had to maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions and
manages them for you so the solution to
this is the use of containers so uh you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know uh 15 20 years
ago you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center and more
recently you probably post your code to
a virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're they're
isolated environments very easy for
developers to work in them but it's also
really easy for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step and back and look at a competing
product to kubernetes which is docker
swarm now one of the things that we have
to remember is that uh docker um
containers which are extremely popular
um built by the company docker and made
open source and docker actually has
other products one of those other
products is dr swann and docker swarm is
a tool that allows you to be able to
manage multiple containers so if we look
at some of the uh the benefits of using
docker swarm versus kubernetes and one
of the things that you'll find is that
both tools have strengths and weaknesses
but it's really good that they're both
out there because it helps keep it
really kind of justifies uh the
importance of having these kind of tools
so a kubernetes was designed originally
from the ground up to be auto scaling
whereas docker swarm isn't the load
balancing is automatic on docker swan
whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for docker
swarm is really fast and easy i mean you
can be up and running within minutes a
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's when you compare the two docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with docker swarms cluster
stream isn't um as strong when compared
to kubernetes now you compare it to
anything else on the market it's really
good um so this is kind of a splitting
hairs kind of comparison um but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability i mean kubernetes was
designed for by google to scale up and
support uh google cloud network
infrastructure they
both allow you to be able to share um
storage volumes with docker you can
actually do it with any container with
that is managed by the docker swamp
whereas with kubernetes it manages the
storage with the podge and a product can
have multiple containers within it but
you can't take it down to the level of
the container interestingly uh
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface um for being able to control
and manage uh the environment the
reality however is that you're likely to
be using terminal uh to actually make
the controls and commands to control
your
either docker swarm or kubernetes
environment and it's great that it has a
gui and to get you started but once
you're up and running you're going to be
using terminal window for those fast
quick administrative controls that you
need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at is
extremely lightweight
it
allows you to have if you compare it to
like a virtual machine which is very
heavy and you know kubernetes is
extremely lightweight and harder uses
any resources at all interesting enough
though is that if you are looking at the
usage of cpu it's better to actually
take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so let's kind of pivot
and look at the software components as
compared to the hardware components so
the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container runs on linux so if you have
docker installed as a developer on your
machine it's actually running inside of
linux and that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of the things
that you'll find is that most data
centers and cloud providers now are
running predominantly on linux inside of
the um the the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a pod is
really just a group of containers
bundled together and
the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server then actually manage what how the
pods are actually pushed out into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use um to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of um manual management of
pods if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
services is on ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster and again this is done
securely through ssl layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is um we looked at this
uh diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which uh
controls the
scheduling the communication um and the
actual
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node network and each
node has various pods so we like break
this down so the master node is the most
vital component and with the master you
have four key controls you have etc
controller manager scheduler and api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation and then we'll work with the
output control schedule and api server
to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an api
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful apis which
can be packaged in ssl to communicate
back and forth um across your uh pods
and the master and indeed the services
within each of them as well so um at
every single layer of abstraction uh the
communication is secure uh the schedule
as the name would imply really schedules
um when tasks get sent out to the actual
nodes themselves uh the nodes themselves
are are dumb nodes they just have uh the
applications um running on them the
master and the scam is really doing all
of the work uh to make sure that your
entire network is running um efficiently
and then you have the api server which
has your rest commands and the
communication and back and forth across
your networks that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so
a work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers on
a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node you have
docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your kubelet which is a
service for conveying information back
and forth um to the service about the
actual health of the kubernetes node
itself and then finally you have the
proxy server and the proxy server is
able to manage the nodes the volumes the
the creation of new containers um and
actually helps pass the communicate the
health of the container back up to the
master to see whether or not the
container should be either killed stop
started or um updated so finally let's
look and see where kubernetes is being
used by other companies so you know
kubernetes is being used by a lot of
companies and they're really using it to
help manage complex existing systems so
that they can have a greater performance
and with the end goal of being able to
delight the customer increase value to
the customer and enhance increased value
and revenue into the organization so
example of this is a company called
blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes uh so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure and
so they actually went and pivoted to
using kubernetes and this allowed them
to be able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine kubernetes was then hooked into
their entire existing system and has
really become a key part of the success
that blackrock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure and the
bottom line is that blackrock is now
able to have confidence in their
infrastructure and be able to give that
confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at offset i would like to cover the
basics of orchestration tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubuntis i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvurnis architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or lifecycle management using
some or the other kind of a tool so
that's where these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide is
you'll have to just let them know what
are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
organization tool becomes a one-stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swamp and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missions there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntes just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swamp is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
over 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high and
your application is experiencing more
load so kubernetes can add new nodes to
your cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exist at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in docker
swamp the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so docker swarm gives you an
application level auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as i mentioned earlier
docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loosely
coupled way where you can create swarms
of your choice nodes are allowed to
connect to swarms and quit or leave the
swamps on the fly so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darkest form the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
nodes can be added to a swarm worker
nodes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docker swarm
runs only docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and lot
of other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but lot of other things however
for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also uh when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's the
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each part
can run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to docker's form uh gui so there's not a
good enough ui tool in docker's form at
least the ce edition of it which will
allow you to get to know what is running
on your containers what is the size of
the containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
pertainer which gives you a good
visibility into your running docker
containers however there's nothing at a
swarm level that is provided by docker
kubernetes gives you an out of the box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also club it with some
metrics services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the nodes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way um this is little bit of a good ui
for kubernetes while for docker's form
there isn't anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture what comprises
of the kubernetes cluster what resides
in a master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be one three five
typically an odd number this is as per
the typical cluster management thing
where you would need the master nodes to
be in odd numbers so that whenever
there's any contention in terms of what
needs to be deployed where or where to
give the job to whom and stuff like that
all the masters would cast their vote
and they would decide on the outcome so
that's the master node and there are a
bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cuba ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cubicctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running um cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asks
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right epa server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest
api endpoint and api server is the entry
point in case you don't want uh you know
somebody to access your cluster in case
you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role based access control for this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as i mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there's something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so sleeve nodes or
the worker nodes typically run these
parts so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the pod who has to have access to the
pod what is the state of the pod is it
in a running state is it going down for
some reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the node should be
the container runtime as i mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have docker running on it rkt
running or lkc running on it or any
other
container environment that is running on
it you have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that specific node so that
whenever a job is submitted a
description of what needs to be run as a
part of the pod what should be the image
with it should be powered and what kind
of a container to spin up so that's what
you know when the job is finally
assigned to this particular node it
would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubuntu's cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster and spin up this
cluster on aws platform finally we get
to the demo section of my tutorial now
that you guys are aware as to what is
kubernetes what is the use of kubernetes
you also know at a very very high level
what are the components of a cluster
what is a master node or a control plane
what are the components of a master node
and what should be existing in a worker
node you're probably thinking that it's
maybe pretty hard to kind of set this up
so let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple free node kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and i will be
doing this whole setup on my aws cloud
okay so what is cops cops is nothing but
a simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i'll do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cubicctl which
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cube
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node and submit jobs on my behalf so let
me begin by first logging into my aws
account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose um
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance i will name this as
my cops server all right i would need a
bunch of posts to be opened up so what
i'll do is i'll create a new security
group
called open to the word i would not
recommend that you do this since i don't
want to it will take a long time for me
to specifically
to pick and choose
the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster i don't want to do
that i will open up all the http and
https ports so that it's quicker so i
will say all tcp i would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open http and https and i will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me i will say review and launch all
right so i chose a t2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i've
opened up all the ports and um the
instant details are you've seen what is
that i've chosen all right now important
part is like i would need a key pair i
need to create a new keypad i will call
this as simply learn keys i will
download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
ssh keys with which i need to log into
my ec2 instance so i'll need to convert
this because i'm trying to connect from
my windows box i would need to convert
this into a ppk file so i have puttygen
i'm going to load my set of keys here
and convert that key into a ppk key all
right open all right i would say save
hang on save private key yes i would say
simply learn or simply learn private
private key i will save this here done
that that's all so this is my public key
which is the pem file and this is my ppk
or my private key now using the private
key i will log into my ec2 instance okay
now my ec2 instance is up and running it
is running in this ohio region and this
is the ip address of my public eye
pedals of my machine so let me connect
to it so i use a moba x term which is
nothing but an ssh emulator you can use
putty or any of these sessions which
allow you to do an ssh this is my ip
address of my machine and since i've
spun up an amazon ami the user this is
the default user i would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im role and i will attach this
im role to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a rule called as possibly
corpse roll i will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so i'm going
to click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cops fold
for easy two all right so i'm going to
create a role which has got
administrative access rules i'm going to
create a role so this would ensure that
my ec2 instance from which i'm going to
run my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permissions so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to s3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so i will connect
this role to my running instance all
right so this is my
easy to instant that is running i'll say
action attach attach attach attach
replace im rules so there is no rule as
of now i would want my corpse roll for
this role that i created so i want this
new room to be assigned to my ec2 all
right great now my ec2 instance which is
my cop server has got all the required
permissions so that he can create a
cluster on my behalf great now before
this let me do a sudo m update iphone y
so that any of the because this is a
newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and uh install cops cups
is a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
corpse tool it's installing for me once
it is copied down let me change the mode
so that i can execute it and then also
let me move it to my user local bin so
that it is available for me in my path
okay that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cube ctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the kubernetes cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply learn
kubernetes is the bucket that i created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a dns entry or a dns zone
or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simply learn dot in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hosted zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted song great now let
me come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bash rc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public uh sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my bash rc file
all right so i will just add these two
and copy these and export them out as my
variable i'm going to save this here now
let me ensure that this gets picked up
all right i've got these two that have
configured and i also ensure that these
environment variables are set now let me
create a pair of ssh keys this is to
ensure that i can log into the box that
i'm going to be provisioning as a part
of my cluster ssh hyphen keygen i don't
want to give any parameters let it go to
the home directory with the default name
and without any passphrase all right so
i created a bunch of my key pair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corps create cluster the state of the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create one primary or the master node
and two
worker nodes uh size of my master node
size of the worker nodes are what are
the zones where i want this to be
created and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off so
that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off uh very fast but um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and uh
and that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and uh two nodes or
the worker nodes all right so this is
the command for me to validate the
cluster and i'm gonna try it out first
i'm pretty sure that it will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good five to
ten minutes so what i'll do is i'll
pause the video now and i'll come back
once uh the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good eight to nine
minutes uh since i started my cluster so
let me validate now okay seems good so
there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro subnet so my clusters seem to
be up and running and my cluster name is
simply learn.n so what i would want to
do is now let me just log into the
master and see if i can run some
parts
so let me get back to my insta
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me login to my
since my cluster name is simplyland.and
this is the way to log into my box so
let me get into my box so if you see
here uh this is the host name of the
machine that i'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our the scop
server this is the server now from here
i'm trying to get into the master box
all right so if you see the ip address
has changed i was in a different box i'm
in a different box now if i see host
name you'll find a different host name
so this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep it's 153 this is the
particular house so i'm getting into
this machine now so i started the
cluster from my cop server here it ran
and brought up three nodes so i'm
actually getting into my master node and
see if i can run some parts on it all
right so let me try cuba ctl
get cluster info try cube ctl get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
master node and um one master node and
two worker nodes so let me see if i have
some pods here cube ctl get pods so
there's no pod as of now so what i'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple part just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct i have a simple uh node.js
application that i've built uh i've got
a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker i've registered is
called simply learn docker hub and the
image name that i have here is called my
node app and i will use this image to
power one of my ports that i will run so
this is the way in which i'm going to
launch my pod let me show you these
commands cube ctl run the name for my
deployment that i'm going to run hyphen
iphone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn docker hub forward
slash my node app hyphen f1 replica is
equal to i want two replicas to be
running and the port that i want to
expose this particular part is on 8 0 8
0. so let me run this as soon as this is
run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
i'm not really interested in the
deployment i'm interested in checking if
all the parts are up and running so i
will say cube ctl get but all right so
that was pretty fast so i have two parts
that are running here these are two
replicas because i asked for two
replicas these parts are running so i
can run cube ctl describe pod pickup all
right i can pick up any of the pod name
and see what is the pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image name id this is actually
running my pod which is actually
spinning up a container great so far so
good so in kubernetes the pods can are
ephemeral so they can be there at any
time cannot beat in time if i need to
expose my pot outside i will have to
create a service for my part so what
i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply run app so
i'll expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i'm not specifying what
type and all i don't want to get into
the complications of uh what are the
different types of exposing the service
and all that stuff so if i don't specify
anything uh it gives me something called
a cluster ip so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this part is up and running i'll
just try a simple curl command curl http
colon this is my cluster ip and uh the
port is 8080 if at all i had this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me whatever
i put a simple uh sys dot out kind of a
thing where i'm just printing um the
container id of whatever pod is serving
uh makes a lot of so i'm actually
hitting my container and i'm getting
this output from the container so
everything looks good my container is up
and running so let me just go and clean
it up i'll say cube ctl
delete deployment simply learn app this
should get rid of all the parts that i
created cube cdl get pod all right these
spots are intimidating things let me
just check cube ctl get services there's
one service i don't want this service
let me delete that cube ctl delete
service i want this all right that
sounds good so let me come back to my
host my cop server from where i'm
running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and complete this uh demo by
going and uh getting rid of my cluster
so corpse delete cluster hyphen f1 yes
all right so this will ensure that it
will clean up my complete cluster that i
created so i had three or four running
instances if you see that all the three
are shutting down because you know the
cop server which had cops installed on
it uh has now got a mandate to go ahead
and shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my deployment hey
everyone i welcome you all to this
puppet fill course by simply learn in
this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know to excel
in puppet we have math and anjali to
guide us through this journey we shall
begin with having a basic understanding
of puppet and what is its relevance
today
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand the components of puppet
followed by its architecture
after checking its architecture we shall
look at the process to install puppet
and configure it in our local system
moving forward we shall see companies
that have adopted puppet and all about
writing manifest and puppet after that
we will check regarding the puppet
community and puppet dsl post switch we
shall see the hands-on demo that will
explain the working of puppet from
scratch
after we have ample knowledge regarding
the tool we shall understand the
difference between chef puppet ansible
and salt stack
finally we shall take a look at some of
the interview questions that might
increase your chances of cracking any
puppet interview so before we begin make
sure that you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to
click that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
now without further ado let's begin with
our introduction hello this is matthew
from simply learn we're going to focus
specifically on puppet so in this
session what we're going to do is we're
going to cover what and why you would
use puppet what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with puppet
all you have to do is write a simple
script that can be written with ruby and
write out and deploy to the servers your
settings for each of those servers the
code gets pushed out out to the servers
that are having problems and then you
can choose to either roll back to those
servers to their previous working states
or set them to a new state and do all of
this in a matter of seconds and it
doesn't matter how large your server
environment is you can reach to all of
these servers your environment is secure
you're able to deploy your software and
you're able to do this all through
infrastructure as code which is the
advanced devops model for building out
solutions so let's dig deeper into what
puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of it the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet master is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it
so manifest is the first subcomponent of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master associated with this
client certificate is the host name of
system a now master goes through the
certificate it sees the host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
i am willing to exchange information
with this system and i do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master signs the certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request
after this request the factor service
which is present on your clients
collects all the information regarding
the present state of your client so this
information could include the operating
system that's installed on them the
various number of software present on
them the versions of these software now
all this information is collected it's
called the fact and it's sent over to
the master at the master this
information that is the facts is
compared against the manifest so why
does the master do this the master
basically compares the facts against
manifest to know if what the manifest is
about to perform is already performed on
these systems so if the manifest has
some additional functionality they are
compiled into catalogs and then these
catalogs are sent over to the client now
remember those agent services which
existed in your clients here's where
they come in the agents take the catalog
and execute them on the client once
executed these catalogs make the
required changes on the client and a
report is generated this report is then
sent back to the master so the master
keeps record of all the changes that's
made in the system and this comes very
handy when one of the systems fail and
it's required to be rolled back to its
previous working state so this entire
procedure can be repeated n number of
times and can be repeated at regular
intervals so if you have a scenario
where a system needs to be configured
every 30 minutes what you can do is you
can set your interval and automatically
every 30 minutes your systems will be
configured if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so today i'll be showing you how you can
use puppet to install apache on one of
your client machines so we'll be using
two machines here we'll have a server
and we'll have a node machine the server
is essentially your master the node is
your client i'm just using the term
server and node instead because i want
to keep it very close to as they are
used in the commands now both these
machines are going to be sent to a seven
machines and i have oracle vm virtualbox
installed on my machine so on that i've
simply created two virtual boxes both
centos 7 of course so before we move on
to the actual demo i'll just take you
through the various steps so first we'll
install the puppet server on our server
or master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start the service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize the certificate and then it
will sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the manifesto is just the codes for
configuration and once that tool is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your catalogs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course is the client so
let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the
hostname the last word you see there
that's the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the ip of this
machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's a command to download the
puppet lab
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need gb
so we are going to reduce the size
512 mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just changed this to xms
512 m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine let's move on to our
client machine
okay first things first we open our etc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet server is installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an ssl certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so a certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate the name of the certificate
itself is usually the host name of the
machine so our certificate's name should
be localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see here the certificate
is signed sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line now that a
certificate is signed we can begin to
write a manifest so let's move into a
manifest folder and we'll create a
placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file
we won't be writing anything in this
file as of now so we are just checking
here we are just creating this file and
then we'll go to our client machine and
just check the if we can access this
file from there
so now we will move to our client
machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so a catalog is
executed
on our client machine
now a catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is our client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just cleared the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache
so as you can see we have successfully
used puppet to install the apache
service on our puppet client
and this is the end of our demo so let's
have a look at companies that are using
puppet today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppy today
include spotify google att so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool the answer can be seen if we look
at a specific company staples so staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in pocket so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific
node in your server environment the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
now we step through the five key steps
for writing a manifest they are one
create your manifest and that is written
by the system administrator two compile
your manifest and is compiled into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent and then five end clients are
configured to a specific and desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written it's written with a
very common syntax if you've done any
work with ruby or really configuration
of systems in the past this may look
very familiar to you so we break out the
work that we have here you start off
with a package file or service as your
resource type and then you give it a
name and then you look at the features
that need to be said such as ip address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types if we continue to write
our manifest and puppet the default
keyword applies a manifest to all
clients so an example would be to create
a file path that creates a folder called
sample in a main folder called etc the
specified content is written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say we want to be
able to trigger an apache service and
then ensure that that apache service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you'll have exactly the same results
on those machines now let's have a look
at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are 4 893 modules on the official
puppet forge these include modules from
the puppet labs and also from open
source contributors to github
so that's nearly 5 000 modules of
ready-made code available on the puppet
forge so before you write any code for
puppet you can check to see if it's
already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
sixty five hundred and eighty eight
participants apart from this on slack
overflow you have a big tag of puppet
labs and puppet which gives you a list
of only puppet questions that's a good
playground for you to interact with
people who are already using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs that has almost five thousand
modules of puppet code so these are both
puppet labs and community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those five thousand
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs one of the other
benefits is they have built-in tests so
they follow all of the best practices
now if you write your own module you
also have to write your own tests and
you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and share with the community the puppet
dsl puppet dsl is a puppet domain
specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it it's kind
of a sub child of ruby because it
approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things so
it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify services to
be managed you can do things based on
the operating system that you have so
we'll be writing a small puppet module
which will be using this puppet dsl
we will do that after we install the
puppet server and the client and then we
will write a simple puppet module to
show how to use the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be setting up
the machines using pseudo dns because we
want to have a resolvable dns because
only by having a resolvable dns can we
use puppet because puppet uses the ssl
certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates of the client on the
server side and then we'll proceed with
writing an ntp module which we'll be
using for installation of ntp on the
client
and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl now we're
going to look at a demo here so we will
be setting up the machines we'll set up
a pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client will be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
[Music]
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client i have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of ram
and four v cpus which i can show you
here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses right click
normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then i will
change the host name so i'll say vim etc
hostname
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a dd which will delete
that existing host name
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both these machines are ready
i'm going to find out the ips and use
the mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns which
means a fully resolvable dns name so if
i do hostname here you see my host name
is puppetmaster in order to set up a
fake dns i need to go to the etc hosts
file
go to the end
then i say ip address host name local
then space host name
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a hostname hyphen f
you see it has a fully qualified domain
name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is xenial
so i'll say curl hyphen 0 https
apt.puppetlabs
dot com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command so i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my app package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get install
puppet hyphen
puppet server hyphen wide
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so i'll
say etc default puppet server so by
default
it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that i'll now start the puppet server so
i'll say a system ctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
i'll also enable it at boot time so i'll
say systemctl enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time
now i also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server dot local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a host name hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the ip
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a hostname
now we also need to set up the fake dns
here so i'll copy this hostname
open the host
line go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name
so when i do a host name
it says puppet hive and client when i do
a host name hyphen f it says puppet
client local to install the puppet agent
on this machine i will need to download
the zenio packages so i'll say wget
https
apt.puppetlabs.com
slash puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc one hyphen
xenial.net
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs iphone release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here and then i'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apt
caches on this machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time so i'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
hyphen agent dot local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local
it is able to ping it and if i ping the
master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.loco
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so i'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and i'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the puppet master then i'll say
hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates
and when i go to the server on the
client side if i run the puppet agent
again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so search for apache module
here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install this is the
command for that but i will make sure i
run this command from the puppet home so
i'll go to the master i'll go to etc
puppet labs
code environments production
in this i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install
puppet labs hyphen apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version
and i'll hit enter
when i press enter it starts downloading
from the forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat stdlib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here etc puppet labs code
environments production manifest so in
this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify
and this is the main controller of how
the infrastructure looks in the site pp
i specify
that i want puppet hyphen client dot
local node to have the apache module
included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now is
since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module and compile
it and it may then make sure the server
is in a state so when i press enter we
see a lot of output it tries to
configure apache on this machine and
done now when i go to the front end of
this machine on this port i should be
able to see apache's default page so
this is apaches default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it's running
here
and that is all we have from the
puppet module
and this concludes the demo today we're
going to go through a real tough battle
we're going to decide which is better
for your operations environment is it
chef puppet antipal or salt stank all
four are going to go head to head so
let's go through the scenario of why
you'd want to use these tools so let's
meet tim he's our system administrator
and tim is a happy camper putting and
working on all of the systems in his
network but what happens if a system
fails if there's a fire a server goes
down well tim knows exactly what to do
he can fix that fire really easily the
problems become really difficult for tim
however if multiple servers start
failing particularly when you have large
and expanding networks so this is why
tim really needs to have a configuration
management tool and we need to now
decide what would be the best tool for
him because configuration management
tools can help make tim look like a
superstar all he has to do is configure
the right codes that allows him to push
out the instructions on how to set up
each of the servers quickly effectively
and at scale all right let's go through
the tools and see which ones we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
are chef puppet and support and salt
stacks and we have videos on most of
these software and services that you can
go and view to get an overview or a deep
dive in how those products work so let's
go and get to know our contestants so
our first contestant is chef and chef is
a tool that allows you to configure very
large environments it allows you to
scale very effectively across the entire
ecosystem and infrastructure chef is by
default an open source code and one of
the things that you find is a consistent
metaphor for the tools that we recommend
on simply learn is to use open source
code the code itself is actually written
in language of ruby and erlang and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my sql
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and
cons the pros for chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
git really well and provides for really
good strong version control some of the
consoles are really around the learning
speed it takes to go from beginner user
with chef to being an expert there is a
considerable amount of learning that has
to take place and it's compounded by
having to learn ruby as the programming
language and the main server itself
doesn't really have a whole lot of
control it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network all right let's look at our
second contender puppet and puppet is
actually in many ways very similar to
chef there are some differences but
again puppet is designed to be able to
support very large heterogeneous
organization it is also built with ruby
and uses dsl for writing manifests so
there are some strong similarities here
to chef as with a chef there is a master
slave infrastructure with puppet and you
have a master server that has the
manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then pushed out to the clients of an ssl
connection some of the pros with puppet
is that as with chef there is a really
strong community around puppies and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed reporting mechanism that makes
it easier for you as an administrator to
be able to understand your
infrastructure one of the cons is that
you have to really be good at learning
ruby again as with shaft you know the
more advanced tasks really need to have
those ruby skills and as with chef the
server also doesn't have much control so
let's look at our third contender here
ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is the way the ansible
works is that it actually just pushes
out the instructions to the server
environment there isn't a client server
or master slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowell stands for yaml 8 markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know xml and xml is pretty easy if
you know xml you're going to get yamo
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focus is
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way the
ansible works is that you have a
playbook and the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yamo
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now i do have to add a
proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and gamble itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here sort stack so source
stack is a cli based tool it means that
you will have to get your command line
tools out or your terminal window out so
you can actually manage the entire
environment via salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yammer or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that sort snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with salt stack
so substance is very easy to use once
it's up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that
source tank is fairly late in the game
when it comes to actually having a
graphical user interface for being able
to create and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a ui environment for quite
some time all right so we've gone
through all four tools let's see how
they all stack up next to each other so
let the race begin let's start with the
first stage architecture so the
architecture for most of our
environments is a server client
environment so for chef puppet and salt
snack so very similar architecture there
the one exception is ansible which is a
client only solution so you're pushing
out the instructions from a server and
pushing them out into your network and
there isn't a client environment that
there isn't a two-way communication back
to that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is ansible it is going to be
the easiest tool for you to set up and
if you are new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
chef puppet and socksec aren't that hard
to set up either and you'll find there's
actually some great instructions on how
to do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use in your configuration so we have
two different types of language with
both chef and ansible being procedural
in that they actually specify at how you
actually supposed to do the task in your
instructions with puppet and sort stack
it's decorative where you specify only
what to do in the instructions let's
talk about scalability which tools scale
the most effectively and as you can
imagine all of these tools are designed
for scalability that is the driver for
these kind of tools you want them to be
able to scale to massive organizations
what do the management tools look like
for our four contenders so again we have
a two-way split with ansible and sort
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're gonna love using them
they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and softstack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chef are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layer and ansible and saltsec
use secure socket hashing and ssh as
their communication tool bottom line all
four tools are very secure in their
communication so who wins well here's
the reality all four tools are very good
and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to manage that will
determine which of these four tools you
should use the tools themselves are open
source so go out and experiment with
them there's a lot of videos our team
has done a ton of videos on these tools
and so feel free to find out other tools
that we have then covered so you can
learn very quickly how to use them but
consider the requirements that you have
and consider the capabilities of your
team if you have ruby developers or you
have someone on your team that knows
ruby your ability to choose a broader
set of tools becomes much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding then you may want to consider
yaml-based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
coming up with because we'll help answer
those challenges for you answer will
provide you with one of the easiest ways
to automate your application and i3
infrastructure on that note hi guys
welcome to this complete ansible
tutorial by simplylearn in this video
we'll be covering some of the most
important concepts relating to the
devops tool ansible we'll take you
through how you can install ansible and
how you can use the tool to automate
your processes first we have anjali to
tell us how to install ansible on your
system
a very warm welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn and today
i'll be showing you how you can install
the configuration management tool
ansible so let's have a brief about why
one would use ansible and what exactly
is ansible so if you consider the case
of an organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
guiamil and these codes are deployed
onto the hundreds and thousands of
servers which configures them to the
desired states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
traits so ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we'll specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of
information follow this up with your
password in my case it's the roots
password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write a
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to our note system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running state and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything is working fine so
our webpage is displayed here so we come
to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible thanks actually now we have
matthew and anjali to take us through
how to work with ansible ansible today
as one of the key tools that you would
have within your devops environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you and your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
then we're going to dig into the
architecture for ansible we're going to
look at how you would create a playbook
how you would manage your inventory of
your server environments and then what
is the actual workings of ansible as a
little extra we're going to also throw
in ansible tower one of the secret
source solutions that you can use for
improving the speed and performance of
how you create your ansible environments
and finally we're going to go through a
use case by looking at hootsuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the dev ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of sam and like
yourselves sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
apache they could be database servers
running uh mysql and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain i mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it would we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where anspo
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following set up
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible hat is a tool that really allows
you to create and control three key
areas that you'd have within your
operations environment first of all
there's it automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the it setup that you would
typically do manually in the past
the second is the configuration and
having consistent configuration imagine
setting up hundreds of apache servers
and being able to guarantee with
precision that each of those apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up a
different
environments for server farms
one is to have a key server that has all
the instructions on and then on each of
the servers that connect to that main
master server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment so when
you're setting up an ansible environment
the first thing you want to do is have a
local machine and the local machine is
where you're going to have all of your
instruction and really the power of the
control that you'd be pushing out to the
remote server so the local machine is
where you're going to be starting and
doing all of your work connected from
the local machine are all the different
nodes pushing out the different
configurations that you would set up on
the local machine the configurations
that you would write and you would write
those in code within a module so you do
this on your local machine for creating
these modules and each of these modules
is actually consistent playbooks the
local machine also has a second job and
that job is to manage the inventory of
the nodes that you have in your
environment the local machine is able to
connect to each of the different nodes
that you would have in your hardware
network through ssh clients so a secure
client
let's dig into some of the different
elements within that architecture and
we're going to take a first look at
playbooks that you would write and
create for the ansible environments so
the core of ansible is the playbook this
is where you create the instructions
that you write to define the
architecture of your hardware so the
playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yammer and this is
a standard language used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml 8 markup language that's just a
little tidbit to hide behind your ear so
let's have a look on one of these
playbooks it looks like and here we have
a sample yaml script that we've written
so you start off your yaml script with
three dashes and that indicates the
start of a script and then the script
itself is actually consistent of two
distinct plays at the top we have play
one and below that we have play two
within each of those plays we define
which nodes are we targeting so here we
have a web server in the top play and in
the second play we have a database
server that we're targeting and then
within each of those server environments
we have the specific tasks that we're
looking to execute so let's step through
some of these tasks we have an installed
apache task we have a start apache task
and we have an installed my sql task and
when we do that we actually execute a
specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
apache and then setting the state of the
apache environment or starting the
apache environment and setting up and
running the my sequel environment
so this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with yaml is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server where do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage and the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible
so the inventory part of ansible is
where we maintain the structure of our
network environment so what we do here
is part of the structure in creating
different nodes is we've had to create
two different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database server node
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointing to specific machines within
that environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yammer
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so let's ask you a simple question
what are the major opportunities the
ansible has over chef and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below pop them in there and
we'll get back to you and really want to
hear how you feel that ansible is a
stronger product or maybe you think it's
a weaker product as it compares to other
similar products in the market here's
the bonus we're going to talk a little
bit about ansible tower so ansible tower
is an extra product that red hat created
that really kind of puts the cherry on
the top of the ice cream or is the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command line tool however asphalt tower
is a framework that was designed to
access ansible and through the asphalt
tower framework we now have an easy to
use gui this really makes it easy for
non-developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their devops plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or a command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes all right so we
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
gonna look at hootsuite now hootsuite if
you not already use their products and
they have a great product hootsuite is a
social media management system they are
able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
hootsuite the challenge they had at
hootsuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite today the devops team at
hootsuite write out playbooks that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of
seconds
the bottom line is ansible has been able
to provide hootsuite with it automation
consistent configuration and free up
time from the operations team so that
instead of managing servers they're able
to provide additional new value to the
company a very warm welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be taking you through a
tutorial on ansible so ansible is
currently the most trending and popular
configuration management tool and it's
used mostly under the devops approach
so what will you be learning today you
learn why you should use ansible what
exactly is ansible the ansible
architecture how ansible works the
various benefits of ansible and finally
we'll have a demo on the installation of
apache or the http package on our client
systems we'll also be hosting a very
simple web page and during this demo
i'll also show you how you can write a
very simple playbook in yaman and your
inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and share
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to english we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
ssh ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the notes and thus it's called a
push configuration tool now the
playbooks and the inventory are written
at the local machine and the local
machine connects with the notes through
the ssh client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the playbook is executed
the task mentioned in the playbook is
compared against the current status of
the node and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
nodes are configured to the desired
states so as i mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client and note systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
important basically means that if you
have a playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file so a host
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root
and become true is basically to indicate
that you need to set your privileges at
root so that's called a privilege
escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we're doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name
so yeah that's pretty much it so when
you write your yaml file the language is
pretty simple very readable indentations
absolutely necessary make sure all your
spaces are correctly placed we can now
save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbook is executed as you can
see here gathering facts that's where
all the facts of the note that the
present state of the note is collected
and sent to the local machine so it's
basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are
made zero clients are unreachable and
zero tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our
client so this is my client machine so
to check this since we are installing
the http package and hosting a web page
the best way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hey there
are you exploring test automation are
you wondering why everyone is talking
about selenium around you do you want to
know what selenium is all about if yes
this is the video for you simplylon
brings to you a very simple tutorial on
selenium what should you expect from
this video before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a facebook
application and in facebook application
let's let's open the facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
these test cases ready what do you do
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the parks are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done annually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions tester's presence is required
all the time one is to keep doing manual
steps step by step again all the time he
also has to create manual reports group
them format them so that we get good
looking reports also send these reports
manually to all stakeholders then
collection of logs from various machines
where you have run your tests
consolidating all of them creating
repositories and maintaining them and
again since it's all as a manual process
there is a high chance of creating
manual errors there scope of manual
testing is limited for example let's say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
you will pick and choose your test cases
to execute that way you are limiting the
scope of testing also working with large
amount of data manually is impractical
which could be the need of your
application what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on application
under test and hence manually performing
these kind of tests is not feasible and
to top it all up say if you are working
in an agile model where code is being
churned out by developers testers are
building their test and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
available for testing and this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run this test multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely becomes very tedious
and boring and is this the effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
automate one for faster execution two to
be less error prone and three the main
reason is to help frequent execution of
our test so there are many tools
available in the market today for
automation one such tool is selenium
birth of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like say rft and qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks and he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing he realized the inefficiency in
manually testing this web application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript testrunner later
he made this open source and this was
renamed as the selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence and
since then selenium has become one of
the most powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages
also selenium supports different
operating systems it has supports for
windows macs linux even ubuntu as well
so you can run your selenium test on any
platform of your choice
and hence selenium is the most popular
and widely used automation tools for
automating your web applications
selenium set of tools so let's go a
little more deeper into selenium as i
said selenium is not a single tool it is
a suite of tools so let's look at some
of the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium ide it's the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is
integrated development environment
earlier selenium ide was available only
as a firefox plugin and it offered a
simple record and playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real-time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record and
replay too selenium rc this is nothing
but selenium remote control it is used
to write web application test in
different programming language what it
does it basically interacts with the
browser with the help of something
called as rc server and how it interacts
its uses a simple http postgate request
for communication this was also called
as selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute text test cases it is obviously
the successor of the selenium rc which
we talked about because of certain
drawbacks which rc had so what webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike rc where the rc required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an ide rc and grid and as i said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
rc so rc was on its path of deprecation
and web driver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of webdriver and also
the rc so they coexisted from 3. onwards
rc was completely removed and webdriver
took its place there is also a four dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancements some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved id and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use too it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selenis commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium id was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium id died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as an add-on
on firefox browser so they completely
revamped this ide code and now they have
made it available on the github under
the apache 2.0 license and for the demos
today we'll be looking at the new id now
with this new ide also comes a good
amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your effects conditions the
while loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ide icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so i already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it's going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i'm just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now it
will enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says fb login which is my test case
name completed successful let's look at
few components of this id the first one
is the menu bar so let's go to our id
all right so the menu bar is right here
on the top so here is your project name
so either you can add a new project here
or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
as facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then id has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever i run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if i just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the first command which is
opening of facebook right i think which
is already done here yeah all right so
once this is done it is going to wait
immediately on the second command and it
says positive debugger so from here you
can do whatever you would like to do in
case you want to change the command here
you can do that you can pause your
execution you can resume your execution
here right you can even completely stop
your test execution or you can just
select this to run the rest of the test
case so if we say run the test case what
it is going to do is just going to
simply go ahead and complete the com
complete the test case now there is
another option here which is you see the
timer there it says test execution speed
so to execute your test cases in the
speed you want say whenever you're
developing an automation script right
and say you want to give a demo so you
need to control the speed sometimes so
that the viewer is able to exactly see
all the steps which is being performed
and this gives you an option to control
that complete execution right so do you
see the grading here so we have
somewhere from fast to completely slow
execution so the previous demo which i
showed was i control the speed and then
i executed it so that we could see every
command how it is being executed all
right so what's the next this is called
as an address bar so whichever whenever
whenever you enter an url here that is
where you want to conduct your test and
another thing what it does is it keeps a
history of all the urls which have used
for running your test then here is where
your script is recorded so each and
every instruction is displayed here in
the order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or failed so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if i click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is a details of this
command which i have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this id so
with this you'll get an idea how do we
actually record scripts in id so for
that i have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon dot in then we'll
search simply search for say product
iphone and once we get that search page
where all your iphones are displayed we
will just do an asset on the title of
the page simple all right so let's do
that so first thing what i need is an
url okay so first let me go to my
firefox browser here and say amazon.com
so why i'm doing this just to simply get
the right url absolute url path here and
so that i don't make any mistakes while
typing in the url okay so i got this so
let me close all this windows i don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what i'll do in the tests
tab i'll say add a new test and name
this test as
amazon search
done i'll say add now i'll enter this
url which i just copied it from my
browser okay and then i'll just say
start recording so what a dot did was
since i've entered the url in this
address box it just opened the amazon
dot in url now let's do our test case so
in my test case what i said was i want
to search for iphone once i have this
i'm just going to click on my search
button so now this gives me a list of
all iphones and then i said i want to
add an assertion on the title of this
page so for me to do that what id gives
me an option is i have to just right
click anywhere on this page and you'll
see the selenium id options here so in
this i will select assert title and then
i will close this browser so that kind
of completes my test case so now take a
look at all the steps which is created
for me so it says open slash because
i've already provided the url here so
either you can replace it with your
regular url or you can just leave it as
it is so what i will do since this is
going to be a proper script and i might
be using this to run it from a command
prompt also so i'll just replace this
target with the actual url and then what
it is doing it is setting a window size
then there are whatever i did on that
particular url on that website it has
recorded all the steps for me so this is
where it says type into this particular
text box which is my search box and what
did it type iphone this was the value
which i entered now there was one more
feature which i told you in this new id
which had which i said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this id is equal to tab search
textbook this is nothing but that search
box where we entered the text iphone and
it has certain identification through
which this ide identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is id is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
css and the xpath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if amazon dot
in website changes the id of this
element
right you are not going to come and
rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular id fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the id it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of these becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
asa title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then i have also
given a closed browser so right now what
i will do is i'll just comment this out
why because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current test day so your amazon n is
launched okay it was typed in the iphone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the log so it's going to be a
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
facebook is also in the same lock so we
will have to see the log from running
amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right was executed successfully
assert title was also done and your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i just
add double s here now this by
intentionally i am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so i'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous
window all right done and now
here i'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which i'm
going to see which i should be able to
see it in the logs so i'll close the
browser after the execution of test case
okay so let's simply go and run the test
case okay amazon.com is launched it
should search for iphone now yeah there
you go all right
now it should also close the browser yes
it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on amazon.in failed actual result
was something different and it did not
match with what we had asked it for so
this is how simple it is to use your id
to create your automation scripts
so we saw all the components of id we
saw the record button then i showed you
the toolbar i showed you the editor box
and also the test execution lock so now
let's come to what are the limitations
of this id with ide you cannot export
your scripts your test scripts to web
driver scripts this support is not yet
added but it is in the works data driven
testing like using your excel files or
reading data from the csv files and
passing it to the script this capability
is still not available also you cannot
connect to database for reading your
test data or perform any kind of
database testing with selenium webdriver
yes you can also unlike selenium
webdriver you do not have a good
reporting mechanism with the id like say
for example test ng or repotentie so
that brings us to the next component of
the suite which is selenium rc selenium
remote control so selenium rc was
developed by paul hammond he refactored
the code which was developed by jason
and was credited with jason as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c perl python and ruby it interacts
with the browser with the help of an rc
server so this rfsave server uses a
simple http get and post request for
communication and as i said earlier also
selenium rc was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got dedicated in selenium
2.0 and was completely removed in 3.0
and it got replaced by what webdriver
and we'll see why this happened and what
was that issue which we had with the rc
server so this is the architecture of
selenium remote control at a very high
level so when jason huggins introduced
selenium you know the tool was called as
javascript program and then that was
also called as a selenium core so every
html has a javascript statements which
are executed by web browser and there is
a javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this rca had
one major issue now what was that issue
say for example you have a test script
say test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain like
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a java script from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
a scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot access
any elements outside the domain like as
we said in the example yahoo.com this
was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called a
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your core
your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your php or
your java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these salinis commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http
post and get request and that is how
your rc server and your browser
communicate and how exactly this
communication happens this rc server it
acts like a proxy so say your test
scripts ask to launch a browser so what
happens is this commands goes to your
server and then your rc server launches
the browser it injects the javascript
into the browser once this is done all
the subsequent calls from your test
script right from your test scripts to
your browser goes through your rc and
now upon upon receiving these
instruction your selenium core executes
this actual commands as javascript
commands on the browser and then the
test results are displayed back from
your browser to your rc to your test
scripts so the same cycle gets repeated
right until the complete test case
execution is over so for every command
what you write in your javascript here
or your test script here goes through a
complete cycle of going through the rc
server to the browser collecting the
results again from the rc server back to
your test scripts so this cycle gets
repeated for every command until your
complete test execution is done so rc
had definitely lot of shortcomings and
what are those so rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts which we just saw so that was an
additional setup since it acts as a
mediator between your commands which is
your selenius command and your browser
the architecture of rc is complicated
why because of its intermediate rc
server which is required to communicate
with the browser the execution of
commands takes very long it is slower we
know why because every command in this
takes a full trip from the test script
to your rc server to the core engine to
the browser and then back to the same
route which makes your overall test
execution very slow lastly the apis
supported by rc are very redundant and
confusing so rc does have a good number
of aps however it is less object
oriented so they are redundant and
confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commands
using a click or a mouse down both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is a kind of
confusion which developers used to
create
hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. it's a cross-platform
testing platform so web driver can run
on any platform like say linux windows
mac or even if you have a ubuntu machine
you can run your selenium scripts on
this machine it is a programming
interface to run test cases it is not an
ide and how does this work actually so
test cases are created and executed
using web elements or objects using the
object locator and the web driver method
so when i do a demo you will understand
what this webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like rc so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like
the rc hat so each browser in this case
what happens is each browser has its own
driver on which the application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report and change
so when we talk about the limitations of
web driver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level
what is in webdriver so webdriver
consists of four major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries
right or what we also call it as
language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let us go back to
the presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i'll be showing
you some of this aps right and these are
nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver
that is here and then we have this
browser drivers themselves and as i said
there is a specific driver for each
browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium so let's look at what
these limitations are and if there are
any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications
mobile applications are little different
and they need its own set of automation
tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it
the next limitation so when we talked
about the components of selenium i said
that with webdriver we can achieve only
sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video
on simply learn website on
grid
third limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges uh with
selenium like selenium is not very good
with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the web driver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple
execution speed
it is lower in rc and much faster than
webdriver why because in web driver we
have eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers
it requires an rc server to interact
with the browsers we just talked about
it and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant abs which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality however webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser
on my browser what i'll do is let me
first launch the simply learn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with
simpler and what i am interested in is
the selenium 3.0 training here once i
find this on the web page i need to go
and click on that all right so this is
all the steps which we are going to
perform in this use case okay now so for
writing the test cases i'll be using an
id which is eclipse i've already
installed my eclipse and also i have
installed selenium in this instance of
my eclipse all right so if you can see
the reference library folder here you
will see all the jars which are required
for the selenium to work next another
prereq which is required for selenium
and that is your driver files now every
browser which you want to work with has
its own driver file to execute your
selenium scripts and since for this demo
i'll be working with the firefox browser
i will need a driver file for firefox
now driver file for firefox is the gecko
driver which i have already downloaded
and placed in my folder called drivers
now where did i download this from let's
go ahead and see that so if i go back to
my browser and if you go to your
selenium hq dot website you have to go
to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this you
will see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i'm working on mac this is the file
which i'm using if you're a windows user
you need to download this zip file and
unzip it so once you unzip that you
would get a file called gecko driver for
your firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project
and just place the driver files here so
these are the two prereqs for your
selenium one is importing your jar files
like this and then having your drivers
downloaded and keep them under a folder
where you can reference to okay so now
we'll go ahead and create a class
i already have a package created in this
project so i'll use this project and
create a new class
so i'll say create new java class and
let's call this as
search training i'll be using a public
static void main and i'll click on
finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your code is what you need
to do is you need to define or declare
your driver variable using your class
webdriver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this id is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from org dot open sq dot selenium this
is the package which we will need all
right so you have a driver created which
is of the class web driver and now after
this i'm going to create three methods
all right so first method i will have
for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method i'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which i am going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
i'll be creating and from the public
static void main i will just call these
methods one after the other okay so
let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the firefox browser so i'll say public
void
since my return type is null or there is
no return type for this let's call it as
launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is webdriver dot
gecko
dot driver and i need to provide a value
so value is nothing but the path to the
gecko driver and we know that this gecko
driver which i'm going to use here is
right here in the same project path
under the drivers folder correct and
that is what the path which i'm going to
provide here so here simply i need to
say
drivers slash
gecko driver gec ko all right done and
let me close this sentence all right now
since i'm a mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a windows user and if
you're running your selenium scripts on
the windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be geckodriver.exe
so just make sure that your path which
you mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is i
need to just say driver is equal to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser form so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get
driver.get what it does is whatever url
you're going to give it here in this
double quotes as an argument it is going
to launch that particular website and
for us it's a simply learn website so
what i do as a best practices instead of
typing out the url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that i do not make any mistakes
in the url okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method i need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so
let me relaunch this let's close this
okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id
and then i'll just copy this id from
here go back to eclipse let's write a
method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training
or just search all right now in this i
need to use a command called driver dot
find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what am i going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay
and then i already have a crow path
installed on my firefox so i'll use the
crow path and first test my xbox so i'll
just say double slash let's see what was
that element it has a span tag okay so
i'll have to use pan and at class equal
to and i'll just copy the class name
here and let's see if it can identify
that element yeah so it is able to
identify so i'll just use this x path in
my code so i'll go back to eclipse and
i'll say driver dot find element by dot
x path
and the x path which i just copied from
crow path is what i'm going to paste
here and what is the action i need to do
here i need to say click
done so i have reached a stage where i
have entered this selenium okay and then
i have clicked on the search button once
i do this i know that expected result is
i should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
i should be able to click on that so for
that again i need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so i would again would like
to use a xpath here now this time while
using the x path i'm going to make use
of a text functionality so that i can
search for this particular text so i'll
simply copy this i'll go to my crow path
the tag is h2 so i'll say simply h2
okay and here i'll say text equal to and
this is the text which i copied i missed
out that yes there so i'm just going to
add an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation all right so technically we
have taken all the steps of the use case
and we have written the commands for
that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to
say print the title of this page now
what is the title of this page if you
just hover your mouse on this it says
online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply so what i will do is after doing
all these operations i will just print
out this page title on our console so
for that i have to just do this driver
dot
so let's do a sysop so i'll say this out
system.out.println
okay and here i would say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with
driver dot
get title so this is the command which
we'll be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and it is one single command which i
need to call i will say driver dot quit
okay and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this so i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is i need to
call the method launch browser and then
i'll call the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process
done so technically our script is ready
with all the functionality which we
wanted to cover from our use case now
there are few other tweaks which i need
to do this and i'll tell you why i need
to do this now for example
after we click here right after we click
on the search if you observed on your
website it took a little while before it
listed out all the selenium trainings
for us and visually when you're actually
doing it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of favorites now since
this is a demo for demo purpose what i'm
going to do is i'm going to use a
command called
thread.sleep and i'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this mainly for the demo
purposes you can use a thread.sleep
command now this thread.sleep command
needs us to handle some exceptions so
i'm just going to click on add throws
declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing i'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it
all right so this is done so by doing
this what am i doing i'm ensuring that
before i click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the webpage
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing i'm doing all
right and also now since you're going to
be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly i'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what i'll do is i'll just give a
simple thread dot sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this okay now our
complete script is ready so what i'll do
is i'll just save the script and then we
will simply run the script so to run the
script i'll just say right click run as
java application okay it says ask me to
select and save i have saved the script
now so let's observe how it runs okay
the
simplylearn.com the website is launched
so the selenium text has been entered in
the search box it has clicked on the
search okay all right so now it did
everything whatever we wanted it to do
all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what i have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what i'll do
since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium three dot or
training or not i'll just comment out
the close browser the command okay so we
will not call the close browser so that
the browser remains open and we get to
see whether did it really find the
training link or not okay so let me
close this window we don't need this
firefox window close all tabs and then
i'll just exactly execute the script so
i'll say run as java application so save
the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theodore
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title here all right
so this is a simple way of using the
selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallely so design is
in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run test and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a windows
machine one of them is a mac machine and
another one is say a linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
system like the one which is depicted in
this picture so what you have to do is
first thing is you configure a master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium standalone server and this
talent standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our selenium hq website so you
can see here right on the top it says
selenium standalone server and this is
the latest version available so you just
need to download once you download this
keep a version of this one on your
master machine that is your hub and this
should also be present on your node
machines and there is a certain command
which you can use to install the server
as a node and as a master depending on
your configuration so once that is done
you have your master and
your master or the hub and the nodes
created your master can control on which
nodes you want to execute test now say
if this is a mac machine this is a
windows machine through your master or
your hub you control on which machine
you want to execute what is then also
you could have a multiple combination of
tests like say for example smoke test to
be run on all these nodes that's the
kind of configuration you can create or
a certain component test to be run on
say only windows 10 with an edge browser
or say regression test on mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does this grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you will need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grit it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support so this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping and achieving a
very broad test coverage
and we also saw that pretty easy to use
tool right so you can check out all our
videos and you can it's just a matte
matter of time that you can master the
skill of writing your automation scripts
reusability of course like any
programming language it provides you a
mechanism to reuse your code and avoid
redundancy well again let's see an
overall what are the limitations of
selenium itself now since selenium is
open source that is one of the biggest
advantage now there is a little
disadvantage which comes with that and
what is it you do not have much
technical support because it's an open
source code however there are loads and
loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like apm for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like autoit and cqla which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
webdriver has limited limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
ng report ng and extent report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation how to install
selenium on windows system selenium
installation is a three-step process so
it has certain prereqs the first
prerequisite you need to have java on
your system so we will be installing
java first and then we will be working
with eclipse id so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium for java we will install the
version java 8 and for eclipse we have a
version 4.10 this was the last stable
version which was released in december
last year so i'll be using that version
and selenium we will download the latest
3.14 version okay so let's get started
with our first step which is the java
installation so to install java let's go
to the browser and simply just search
for java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to login
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211. so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we just go and click on
next and then the java installation is
in progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which are installed and then uninstalled
so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i'll just copy this path and
then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 2019 06. so
especially with eclipse since it's an
open source i prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why i have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is
4.10 which was released in last december
so you can always choose to go with the
latest version but then if there are any
issues and if you're like first time
working with the eclipse you're going to
get confused as where these issues are
coming from right so i would still
recommend that you use the last stable
version which is available with your
eclipse so now to get the last table
version what you need to do is go and
click on this download packages and here
if you scroll down this page you can see
here more downloads so there is a list
of all the previous releases of app
eclipse which is available and this is
what we need to download so just click
on that 4.10 version and then click on
the os on which you want to install
eclipse for us it is windows so i'll
just click here on the 64-bit windows
and then click on the download and you
will be downloading the complete package
so once you download this is what it
will look like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the eclipse which i got
now what's the next step i need to do
just launch this installer and install
eclipse so i'll just say double click on
this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developer so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you are going to create
through eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so this is going to take
as my default workspace and all my
programs all my java scripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default jre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
gr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this gives
me an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
java installed on our machine which is
java 1.8 i will say use default grd
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selenium
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org is
going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium web
driver you would be requiring this when
you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
it say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
seleniumhq.org
for us to install selling so let me show
you the folder where i've already
downloaded all this so if you see here
selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selling it and then we also downloaded
the driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jar click on add external jars go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so i
have two jar files here i'll just say
click open again i will click on add
external jar now from the libs folder i
will select all this file so select all
the five jars and click on open so you
should see all the seven jar files here
so once you have this just say apply and
close now if you look into your project
directory here you will see some a
folder called referenced library and
this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts so for us to install java let us
go to our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
okay so we would select the oracle site
for downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on mac this
is the package which i am going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we
will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i've already downloaded so let's
go ahead and install jtk so how do we
install jdk so you have the dmg file
here you just go ahead and double click
on that
okay and then i'll double click on this
package
and then we will say continue
and install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the
software probably it will just take a
couple of minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so i let me close this
window let me close this window tool and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash cell
this is mainly used to export variables
in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot
bash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other parts here already
written because i am working with other
multiple software on this machines and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home
equal
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a
folder called library here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and bin folder so
that means i need to give my java home
path until here
till this home directory so simply what
i am going to do is i'll just go here
say get info because i want to just copy
the path and what you can do is you copy
this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus i want to till the home directory
so i'm just going to type out h o me
home that is it so you have now set your
java home environment variable so simply
you do
save the file
escape colon wq and come out of it and
now what you need to do for this batch
profile
to be activated you just exit out of
this terminal
okay close this terminal window and i
will go ahead and open another terminal
so let me close this
info text so here let me again give java
minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel
this is another way of finding out that
your java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
all right
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what i will do i'll go to my
browser
okay
and
now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you are working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
i would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what we are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions i just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this photo tip this
4.10 was released last year this is 28
in december okay and now when you look
at this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what i would be using is eclipse id
for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me i've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java 2018 12
r
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i am going to double click
on this and install the eclipse let's
see how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch so what i'll
do i'll just simply search for that on
my system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you're going to do
in eclipse all under that particular
directory um so right now it gives me a
default directory rather what i will do
is since i have created a separate
folder for our demos i will go ahead and
select that folder which is my simply
demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i'm going to
create whatever code i'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch
so it will take a minute to load your
workbench yeah there it goes so when you
launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
screen
just go ahead and close the welcome
script and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and create a project first
so i'll simply say open file new java
project let's give a nice name to this
since this is a first project which is
going to be created so i'll say selenium
first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution jre which
you already have in the system that's
why it has already chosen java one dot
it in case you have multiple javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the java of your choice so
say if you have got the latest java
which is java 12 installed on your
system it will give you an option here
along with java software 8 it will give
you java 12 here so you can go ahead and
select that for this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk installed here i
will go ahead and create this project
so i'll just click on finish and it's
going to create a project from so there
are few default things which it grades
created one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we will be creating all our java
code or selenium descripts okay good so
far so this is a simple way of
installing your eclipse and getting your
eclipse ready to work with your selenium
all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot org
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selenium
one is the selenium standalone server
so when you are going to be working with
remote selenium webdriver is when you
would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me okay so i have already downloaded it
and i'll show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you're
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client for me now as i said since i've
already downloaded it so let's go ahead
and look at what are those downloadables
what we have so let's close out this
window now if you see here
one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3 in this folder you have multiple jar
files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs you have
other jar files now these are the files
which we will need and now let's see how
do we utilize this file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so
let me maximize this window so in
eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project
okay
right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
now here in this configure build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium java 3. so what i'll do i'll
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
files what we have is an ellipse so
select all the jar files in the list
say open
you have all the java files what we need
identified here go ahead and click on
apply and close
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selling hello this is matthew
from simply learn and today we're going
to go through part one of a two-part
series on interview questions that you
are likely to be asked if you are
interviewing for a job that focuses on
devops so there are approximately seven
sections that we cover in devops we go
from general devops questions source
code management with tools such as git
continuous integration and here we'll
focus on jenkins continuous testing with
tools such as selenium and then you also
have the operation side of devops which
is your configuration management with
tools such as chef puppet and ansible
containerization with docker and then
continuous marching with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
agile delivery which is on
sprints to where we are with continuous
integration and continuous delivery
around dev ops the whole concept of
devops is culturally very very different
from agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which i see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chat bot or any digital solution that
you have and has an expectation when
you're going through and actually doing
a devops paradigm the old model would be
that you would capture requirements from
the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these barriers between
each of those as we move faster through
from waterfall to agile what we saw is
that with agile we're able to respond
much faster to customer demands so
instead of it being weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases of software what we saw it
would was a transition to weeks and
months for releases on software now we
see with devops is that the release
cycle has shrunk even further with the
goal of continuously delighting the
customer how further has that release
cycle shrunk to there are companies that
have gone from having releases of once a
week or once every two weeks or once a
month to now having multiple releases a
day indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your mobile app they're going
to see responses happening continuously
so that the customer is always aware
that you as a company are listening to
their demands and responding
appropriately you're able to provide a
more stable environment and you're able
to scale that environment to the demands
of the number of customers that are
using your services so how you approach
a project that needs to implement devops
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working in a dev ops the first stage is
an assessment stage and think of this as
the back of the napkin ideation stage
this is where you are sitting with a
business leader and they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is blue sky
opportunity this is thinking of big
ideas that second stage and this often
comes as a fast follow to stage one is
actually proving out that concept so
developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the poc to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the poc so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that being delivered
so that once you actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to backfill the demand of work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production it ensures
that your businesses and functions are
running as you would expect them to be
so it's going through and completing the
code that you'd actually see continuous
deployment in contrast is all about
ensuring that you're automating the
deployment of a production environment
so you're able to go through and scale
up your environment to meet the demands
of both the solution and the customer
this makes software development and
release processes much more faster and
more robust so if we look here we can
actually see where continuous
integration and continuous deployment
come hand in hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration and your
continuous delivery and then at some
point you want to get very comfortable
with deploying the code that you're
creating so it's being pushed out to
your production environment one of the
things that's great about working with
the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment what
this means is that when you actually
come to deploying solutions to
production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management in dev ops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas and the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability to manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
it and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that with being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7 for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self-audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is amazon's
web services aws and they have really
five distinct areas them that you can
zero in on board services so when the
question comes up what is the role of
aws in devops you want to really hold
out your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that aws and
other cloud providers but aws is
certainly the leader in this space are
great for being able to provide support
for the role of devops so one of the
things that we want to be able to do
effectively when we're releasing any
kind of solution is to be able to
measure that solution and so kpis are
very important so you will be asked for
three important dev of kpis and so three
that really come to mind that are very
effective the first one is mean time to
failure recovery and what this talks
about is what is the average time does
it take to recover from a failure and if
you have experience doing this then look
at the experience you have and use a
specific example where you are able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impacts to your network
look like when you're doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so and how
many times did you deploy to a server
and something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then the second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
uh the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environment and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that xml or ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
that software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yaml to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
uh source code management with git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to git is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
version control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up older
technologies such as older versions of
team foundation server though the
current version does actually have git
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files uh for the application and if
the centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows
for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from asia from north america or
south america very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have get push get fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be git clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a github repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command get remote add origin
and then the actual path to a github
repository you could if you want to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as git lab that
you can also work with or a private git
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bare repository and
a standard way of initializing a get
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using git init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
in it and then the folder that creates
is the folder that creates all the
revision history related to the work
that you're doing in contrast using the
bear way you have a different commands
for setting that up so it would be git
init dash dash bear and it does not
contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git in it initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv get rm-r or none of
the above well in this instance it would
be get mv a question that you'll be
asked around commit is going to be what
is the process to revert a commit that
has already been pushed and made public
and there are two ways you can address
this the first is to actually address
the bad file in the new commit and you
can use the command git commit dash m
and then put in a comment for why that
file is being removed the second is to
actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the commit that you had made but
that would allow you to revert any bad
files that you had submitted so the two
ways of being able to get files from a
get repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
git fetch and get paul so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a new repository it does
not integrate any of the new data into
your working files and it can be undone
anytime if you wanted to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast git
pull updates the current head branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
gate stash so as a developer you will be
working on the current branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the mainline branch and this
is called git stash allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and git be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command get diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have uh two
or more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
you want to keep and which you want to
merge and which ones you want to change
so it's a step through how you would
actually resolve a merge conflict and
the first step would be under github you
want to be able to pull the repository
name and then the pull request around
that repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve they'll pull up a file that
will list out all of the conflicts for
you near the bottom of that file will be
a list of the requests that need to be
resolved and then if you need to make a
decision on which branches you want to
keep or which ones you want to change
that will have to be something you have
to put in instructions inside of the
file you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all of
the conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local get repository and
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then
you want to be able to generate a list
of the files that are affected with the
merge conflict and in this instance here
you can actually see the file
styleguy.md has a merge conflict in it
and as before with working with github
you actually go through and use a text
address and use any text editor but as
you go through and edit out what you
want to keep and what you want to
manage in your conflict so you actually
have a resolution that's been created so
that you'll be able to then once you're
using the conflict markers you can
actually merge your files together so
that the solution itself will allow you
to incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
all right let's talk about the next
section which is continuous integration
with jenkins so the first question
you'll be asked about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins so the way that jenkins is set
up is that the jenkins master will pull
code from your remote git repository
such as github and will check that
repository every time there is a code
commit it will distribute the workload
of that code and the tests that need to
be applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins jar java dash war
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java jar jenkins dot
war so when working with jenkins you're
going to be asked what are the key
concepts and aspects of working with the
jenkins pipeline and you want to really
hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user-defined model of a cd
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in maven and do we have a
build.xml
b
palm.xml c dependency.xml
or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain specific language for
jenkins and there are one or more
noteblocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or see you
can actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
hpi plugin file into the jenkins home
plugins subdirectory you want to remove
the plugins development directory if
there is one you want to create an empty
file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disable allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment slash safe restart so let's
go into the fourth and final section of
this first video which talks about
continuous testing with selenium so the
first question you will be asked most
likely around selenium are what are the
four different selenium components and
again you will want to hold open your
fingers because there are four distinct
environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selenium ide you have selenium remote
control or selenium rc you have selenium
web driver and then selenium grid you'll
be asked to explain each of those areas
in more detail but let's start off with
by looking at selenium driver what are
the different exceptions in selenium
webdriver so it's useful to remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow of that
program's instructions and so we have
four we have a timeout exception an
element not visible exception no such
element exception and a session not
found exception and each of those if we
step through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium web driver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancelium test an application in an
android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported tests within selenium so when
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by
cylinder you can answer that and there
are three different types of tests first
is a functional test second is a
regression test and third is a load
testing test the functional test is a
kind of black box testing in which test
case are based on a specific area of
feature within the software a regression
test helps you find any specific areas
that functional tests or non-functional
areas of the code wouldn't be able to
detect the load testing test allows you
to monitor the response of a solution as
you increase the volume of hits in how
you're using the code are put onto it an
additional question you'll be asked is
how can you get a text of a web element
using selenium well the get command is
due to achieve text of a specific web
element it's important to remember
however that the command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction api and the advanced user
interaction api is something that can be
scripted into your tests and it allows
you for
capturing methods such as a click and
hold and drag and drop mass events and
then keyboard down or keyboard up key
release events so that if you want to to
capture say the use of control shift or
a specific function button off the
keyboard you'd be able to capture those
of the following four elements which of
these elements is not a web element
method a get text b
size
c get tag name d send keys and it's b
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
web page that matches the specified
located value in contrast find elements
finds all of the elements on the web
page that matches the specified value
when using webdriver what are the driver
close and driver quit commands and these
are two different methods used to close
a web browser session in selenium so
driver close will close the current web
browser which your focus is set and
driver quick closes all the browser
windows and ends the web driver session
completely the final question that you
are likely to be asked in using selenium
is how can you submit a form using
selenium well in this instance that's
relatively easy the following lines of
code will let you submit a form in
selenium which would be web element el
equals driver dot find element and then
you put in the id and the element id and
then l submit open close parentheses
semicolon so let's just get into the
first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl certificates used for chef
really fundamentally your immediate
answer should be security ssl provides
for a very high level of private
security and private and public key
pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using ssl and you're using the
private public key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked some questions such
as the following which is the following
commands would you use to stop or
disable the http service when the system
boots and you'll typically get four
responses and there'll be
system ctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http dot service system disable httpd or
the final option which is system ctl
disable
dot service your answer should be the
first one which is hashtag system ctl
disable http dot service so chef comes
with a series of tools that allow it to
function effectively and one of the
tools that you're going to be asked
about is what is test kitchen and test
kitchen is essentially a command line
tool that allows you to be able to test
out your cookbook before you actually
deploy it to a real note so some of the
commands that you would use are for
instance if you want to create an
instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge
so a question you'll get is around chef
is how does chef apply differ from chef
client so fundamentally the difference
between them is that chef apply will
validate the recipe that you're working
on whereas chef client looks to apply
and validate the entire cookbook that's
run in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppet and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version 3. now something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class in puppets and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with a previous question within puppet
of a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agent-less installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact and you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation uh docker data volumes
can be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume matches the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed so what are the
commands to create a docker swarm and so
here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and once
you've created a swarm on your magic
node you can now add worker nodes to
that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be taken to be able to effectively
create a swarm so start with the manager
node and then you create a worker node
and then finally when a node is
initialized as a manager node it can
immediately create a token and that
token is used for the worker nodes and
associating the ip address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
dockerfile actually is used for creating
docker images using the build command so
let's go through and show on the screen
what that would look like and this would
be an opportunity where if you're
actually in a technical interview you
could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you are
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub
and you can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read only file
system the docker container is a
collection of the runtime instances of a
docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yaml what can be an
alternate file to build docker compose
so yaml is the one that is the default
but you can also use json so if you are
comfortable working with jason and my
that is something that you should get
comfortable with is you want to be able
to use that to name your files and as a
frame reference json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a javascript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have docker registry
is an open source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing docker
images whereas in contrast for
repositories a collection of multiple
versions of a docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the registry docker also has
its own default retreat called docker
hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that uh support
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in dockerfile whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with publish is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is it's the
command used in docker whereas for
publish we use the command-p for when
we're doing our command line used in
docker and examples of these are expose
8080 or with docker we would put in or
for publish would do the example docker
run d dash p and then
a 0.0.0.80 80 as our command line so
let's look at continuous monitoring so
with continuous monitoring how does
nagios help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and servers and so
this is really just a high level
question of using nagios within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
nagios allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they've been
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any task failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with web services and apis that
are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negatives help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negative process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negatives web interface to be able
to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagios
remote plugin executor or the mpre of
nagios so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
cpu load etc
what are the ports used by nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so i would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six five six six seven and five six
six eight so there are two types of
checks within nine years so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nagios so an active check and
is initiated by the nagios process and
is run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to the
new gears for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negas will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
oil service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagios so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operates so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats two
allows system admins to gather
high-level information on the health of
your network three provides a central
view of your network traffic and
bandwidth data and then 4 allows you to
proactive in resolving outages abnormal
behavior and threats before they affect
critical business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitoring with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how nagios itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including microsoft visual pc
vmware zen amazon ec2 et cetera et
cetera so just make sure you get that
right off the bat now yes it was able to
provide capabilities tomorrow and so
much of metrics on different platforms
it allows for ensure for quick detection
of service and application failures and
has the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including cpu usage
memory networking and vm status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use specifies
the name of the template object that you
want to inherit its properties and
variables from and register indicates
whether or not the object definition
should be registered to dagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can actually write down and
show someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagios
said to be object oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format that you can use in
your object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical object
oriented development and is now applied
for the nagios environment so some of
the objects that you can inherit are
services hosts commands and time periods
so finally explain what is state talking
in nagios and so there are really four
options here when you're talking about
state stalking so state stalking is used
for logging purposes in nagios it allows
you to enable for a particular host or
service that nagios will watch over very
carefully it will log any changes it
sees in the output of the check results
and then finally helps the analysis of
log files and so with that we come to
the end of this devops tools full course
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comments section below
so watch out for more interesting videos
like these until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you